down in the depths of facility 23 a
group of scientists stand before a
massive rumbling piece of Machinery they
all hold their breath as the gigantic
mechanism suddenly stops it's eerily
quiet for a moment before a door slides
open the scientists crane their necks to
see inside to see what the result of
their great experiment was these were
some of the greatest Minds in the SCP
Foundation but nothing could prepare
them for what they had created September
9 2008 was an unseasonably Frosty day
when Dr Charles gears one of the SCP
foundation's most iconic scientists
parked his Honda Civic outside of what
seemed like an innocuous government Cold
Storage Warehouse he sipped his coffee
and surveyed the building which he along
with about a hundred others in total
knew to be site 19 facility 23. why was
Dr gears former director of all Euclid
level containment at site 19 here today
because official testing was about to
begin on
scp-914 the foundation had acquired the
machine now known as scp-914 some time
ago but only after its recent
reclassification to 914 had it been
relocated to facility 23. it must have
been important because the entirety of
the facility was being repurposed for
scp-914 research they were dealing with
an immensely complicated piece of
anomalous technology here and the same
question was on everybody's limbs what
exactly does this thing do Dr Arthur
Hackett the facility director had
requested the cold clinical assistance
of Dr gears in providing the answer once
he'd finish his morning coffee Dr gears
headed inside the facility security
chief agent Alan sedna had been beefing
up security at the building and at least
two mobile task force units were already
on call in case anything happened the
first day of official testing is always
a crap shoot you might get a nice drink
out of it like with scp-294 or you may
get an XK Class end of the world
scenario Mario
you never really know all Dr gears knew
as he walked up the granite steps to the
main entrance was that he was already
feeling exhausted when you've dealt with
anomalous objects and entities for
decades on end the sense of wonder and
Mystery Begins to wear off only to be
replaced with a kind of tedium any
office worker knows all too well
everyone knew that Dr gears was devoted
to the job perhaps more than anyone else
but he approached the job with an
emotionless effect you wouldn't know
from looking at him if he was thinking
about the deadly anomalous creature in
the Next Room or what he was going to
have from lunch that day the doctor
passed through security and was briefed
in the break room by Dr Lucius Veritas
director of research at site 19. he
explained that the machine seemed to
work in the absence of any power source
its mechanical structure is similar to
Machinery from the Industrial Revolution
but it's exceedingly complex for
something constructed in that time
Foundation analyzes into the structure
of the 914 machine have shown it to have
as many as a 8 million moving parts and
that might even be an incomplete
estimate Dr Gears War is trademark blank
phase as he listened solemnly nodded and
asked to be shown the anomaly
he was led into containment chamber 109b
by a pair of guards according to all
current Foundation tests the machine
doesn't appear to pose any active risk
of containment breach or danger to the
guards earning it the rare safe
designation as a result aside from
guards stationed on site containment
procedures for 914 were minimal whether
this designation would need to be
changed after testing was something Dr
gears would soon find out
scp-914 was a truly impressive site to
Behold a giant Clockwork mechanism
taking up around 18 square feet with an
unfathomably complex combination of
screwdrives belts pulleys Springs and
gears a less stoic researcher might see
the humor in recruiting a doctor gears
to test such a device but comedy
definitely wasn't one of Dr Gear's
Specialties he stared at the machine
with a detached Fascination analyzing
its vital components at a glance
gears noted a large mainspring beneath a
rudimentary selection panel the panel is
copper with a large selection knob fixed
to an arrow above a series of different
options rough coarse one-to-one fine and
very fine
there was also a large key below the
selection panel for the purposes of
winding up the mainspring and initiating
whatever procedure this machine was
designed to enact next Dr gears noticed
two large booths connected to the
Machine by a pair of equally large
copper tubes the booth on the left
labeled intake and the right labeled
output incredibly Dr gears was able to
immediately deduce the purpose of this
machine it was designed to enact some
kind of transformative process on
whatever was placed into the intake
Booth but what kind of transformative
process that's exactly what Dr gears was
here to find out the experiment was
simple they would gather a series of
samples both inanimate objects and
living tissue and use them to explore
the different permutations of the 914
machine's transformative abilities this
initial series of experiments were
approved by o5 command and the site
director and with the 47 researchers
present in facility 23 at his disposal
Dr gears commenced his research into
scp-914 to minimize risk Dr gears
decided the first test would be a simple
kilogram of Steel on his orders the
steel was placed into the intake Booth
with the doctor's approval a junior
researcher set the control panel setting
to rough and began twisting the main
spring key at which point the booth
stores closed and a small bell inside
Shine the machine began to rumble its 8
million working pieces churning into
life it continued like this for around
10 minutes before falling silent at
which point the output Booth opened what
had once been a single lump of Steel
weighing one kilogram was now an uneven
pile of smaller lumps with evidence of
laser cutting doctor gears May note of
the fact that having lasers within such
a machine is both anachronistic and
anomalous and that the rough setting
appears to messily cleave the object
placed within the intake Booth into
pieces Dr gears also noted that it would
be unwise to test any kind of explosive
material on the rough setting unless of
course they wanted to destroy the
building the research continued Dr gears
used another one kilogram lump of Steel
to test the one-to-one feature this time
the result was far more peculiar the
output Booth contained the exact same
weight in steel screws this result was
sparking even greater connections and Dr
Gear's impressive analytical mind
firstly the one-to-one feature caused
the 914 machine to transform the output
into something different from but
similar to the intake and while this
would require further testing it
appeared that the 914 machine despite
being anomalous does still follow the
laws of physics samples pass through the
machine conserve their mass and would
not be transmuted on an atomic level
from one element to another
next Dr gears pushed another lump of
Steel through the machine on the fine
setting the result this time was a
kilogram of Steel carpet tax from this
Dr gears was able to ascertain that the
fine feature improves the samples placed
within the intake Booth somewhat however
things got even stranger when gears
performed the same experiment on the
very fine setting the output Booth
provided several unknown gases and a
lump of unknown metal with anomalous
qualities namely it was resistant to
heat up to 50 000 degrees impossible to
bend or break with any force and was a
perfect conductor of electricity
Dr gear suddenly realized his task here
may be more interesting than he'd
initially imagined was that a bit of a
smile on his face that one researcher
spotted surely not this was the famous
unflappable Dr gears after all the
doctor decided to take it up a notch and
began to test more complex items in the
914 machine he removed his own
wristwatch and placed it into the input
Booth before setting the machine to
coarse and letting her rip literally in
this case
when the output Booth was opened the
watch had been painstakingly
disassembled into its component parts
with no damage to said Parts Dr gears
noted the course feature as a more mild
version of the rough in the sense that
it was able to take an object apart
without any kind of fundamental damage
he also made note of the fact he'd need
to get himself a new watch Dr gears then
asked one of the researchers to
surrender their cell phone for testing
while none were excited at the prospect
of their phone getting eviscerated by A
Clockwork Behemoth one of the
researchers eventually surrendered their
Blackberry Curve to the doctor
he placed it into the intake booth on
the one-to-one setting and 10 minutes
later the output Booth released a brand
new Apple iPhone sadly for the
researcher who donated his BlackBerry he
wasn't allowed to keep the new device
naturally Dr gears was interested in
trying out the anomalous very fine
setting on a more complex object seeing
as no other researchers were eager to
hand over their personal effects he took
a cold python revolver from a member of
security and rammed that through the
machine on very fine
the result was an extremely powerful
energy weapon containing gamma radiation
which fired a beam capable of
disintegrating anything in its path
while the weapon's power was immense it
was also too dangerous and unstable to
be added to the foundation's Armory for
General use
having collected a wealth of data from
more complex objects Dr gears was eager
to move to the next stage live test
subjects
while his fellow researchers had some
reservations the experiments pushed on
beginning with mice a single white mouse
was put into the intake booth on the
one-to-one setting and the Machine was
activated
the result five minutes later was an
almost identical creature saved for the
fact that it now had brown fur
encouraged by the fact that the mouse
survived the refinery process Dr gears
next applied for the use of two chimps
in his scp-914 experiments
the first chimp was run through the
machine on the fine setting the result
was a chimp of human level intelligence
who has since begun working for the
foundation under the Alias Dr Bobo and
the data from this test has been
expunged from the official reports to
protect Dr Bobo's privacy the second
primate test this time on rough was not
quite as positive the chimp was
dismembered with the mutilated corpse
showing evidence of cutting from high
heat and crushing
of course everyone knew where these
tests were eventually going Dr gears
requested two members of d-class
personnel for testing the first was a 42
year old Caucasian male weighing 108
kilograms and standing 185 centimeters
tall Dr gears ran him through scp-914 on
the one-to-one setting resulting in a
slightly taller Hispanic man with a
slightly lower body weight
he immediately became severely confused
and agitated and attempted to attack the
guards present leading to his
unfortunate termination by Foundation
staff it was on the final live test that
tragedy truly struck a 28 year old
Caucasian male was run through the
machine on the highly anomalous very
fine setting the result was an utterly
nightmarish creature
so horrifying that the majority of the
details on its physical appearance have
been expunged from the Rapport the
creature made a sudden Escape reaching
the relatively minor containment
procedures intended for the inert
scp-914 this highly dangerous creature
killed eight guards as well as two
senior researchers upon emerging from
the output Booth a special response team
was dispatched to take the creature down
but that proved harder than expected
scp-914 had massively improved upon the
human original especially when it came
to its killing ability eventually it was
captured but the Special Response Team
suffered injuries and memory loss as a
result of the creature's anomalous
powers
the creature was also severely wounded
and its blood caused corrosive damage to
the plumbing in facility 23. the
creature expired from its injuries
several hours later turning into a cloud
of Blue Ash that blinded a nearby
research team Dr gears would later
comment that the experiments were
ultimately still a success in spite of
some minor hiccups testing on the device
continues to this day in an effort to
understand the full potential of the
machine though for obvious reasons
biological testing on the machine has
since been forbidden without direct
authorization from o5 command after all
if an already dangerous SCP was ever
subjected to the very fine
transformation setting we could be
dealing with something beyond our
greatest nightmares
feeling hungry maybe you could go for a
snack right about now or a nice
refreshing can of your favorite soda
perhaps if you've got some change
burning a hole in your pocket a nearby
vending machine would be a good choice
and trust us there's no vending machine
like this one
scp-261 will give you a treat that's out
of this world or rather out of this
Dimension that's how this safe class
anomaly earned its incredibly accurate
name the interdimensional vending
machine it was first discovered in a
dark alley in Yokohama Japan Japan is a
place where you can find a number of
strange and surprising things in vending
machines but nothing quite like this the
foundation was first alerted to its
presence after one of their web trawlers
noticed some interesting chatter on
Japanese online message boards about a
magic vending machine to these Japanese
form users it sounded like a fanciful
urban legend a vending machine where you
could get something truly fantastical if
you have the yen to spare but upon
thorough investigation field agents of
the SCP Foundation discovered that the
machine was no Legend and brought it
into containment it's the kind of thing
you wouldn't look twice at an utterly
generic black vending machine with no
viewing window and a handwritten sign in
Japanese that reads out of order but
what the vending machine looks like
isn't nearly as interesting as what it's
capable of when you insert your money
into the machine and it's important to
note that it only accepts Japanese Yen
the machine will dispense some kind of
snack food or drink item however over
time the more the machine is used in a
single day the more bizarre the items it
spits out will become Foundation
researchers have attempted to figure out
how the machine works but their task has
been incredibly difficult so far it
doesn't appear to contain any snacks and
it doesn't seem to be made of any
anomalous Parts moreover the machine
simply won't work when the front panel
is opened or when any surveillance
equipment is placed inside in other
words it's pretty much impossible to
look this gift horse in the mouth
strangely the machine is also capable of
working without power though when
unpowered the vended products are likely
to become stranger much faster but let's
be honest here you're not here for
vending machine mechanics 101 you want
to hear about all the weird stuff that
scp-261 dispenses and frankly we're with
you on that one lucky for all of us this
is one of the anomalies that the
foundation has truly extensive test
records on providing us with a highlight
reel of some of the strangest wildest
and downright most interesting snacks
and drinks straight out of another
dimension Bon Appetit let's start off
nice and easy with some of the snacks
and drinks that are not only edible but
also sound like they'd actually be
pretty tasty like Pepsi Dragon twist a
bottle of Pepsi soda with English
packaging that tastes like dragon fruit
PepsiCo does not produce such a product
but honestly we wish they did same for
Dark Side Cola a clear liquid that
becomes jet black shortly after being
opened which apparently tastes like your
average can of coke with the Touch of
Spice thrown in but hey not everybody
likes Cola maybe you're a Maverick a
rebel only a soft drink with a formal
title can quench your thirst and as such
you prefer Dr Pepper in which case maybe
the vending machine will furnish you
with an interdimensional Japanese
product known as Dr Pepper's amusing
straw this spatial anomaly wrapped
inside a Whimsical Dr Pepper branded
straw seems to contain far more liquid
than should be able to fit in the straw
about one bottle's worth of soda to be
precise a nice and convenient solution
for whenever you need to get the fix
that only an accredited doctor of
popology can provide and if you fancy
something from the more intoxicating end
of the beverage Spectrum for 600 Yen you
can get yourself a rare bottle of Billy
beer it's just the thing for those who
weren't alive during the Carter
Administration but still want to try
brew that was endorsed by the younger
brother of President Jimmy Carter this
anomalous bottle of Suds which was
bottled in the 1970s according to its
label came with a note reading I had
this beer brewed just for me I think
it's the best I've ever tasted and I've
tasted a lot I think you'd like it too
Bailey Carter drinking the beer got a
d-class intoxicated for 72 hours but
what if you've just wet your whistle and
worked up a hunger in the process
thankfully scp-261 has some delicious
interdimensional food to satisfy your
Cravings so for starters how about a
tube of the little Bakery Seven Grain
this small aluminum tube lets you
squeeze out a blob of dough which
instantly Rises and Cooks itself into a
tasty little loaf of bread testing has
indicated that the bread is a little
chewy but still tastes completely fine
not bad for a tubed baked good how about
some seafood to go with that bread then
maybe for your entree you can crack open
a delicious pack of lemon clams and we
do mean crack very literally here if you
crack this bag of anomalous clams like a
glow stick they boil themselves and once
you open them you're ready to enjoy a
serving of tasty clams that have a
slight lemon flavoring to them delicious
but if you're not that hungry and just
feeling more like a snack than a full
fancy dinner the machine once put out
the Lay's blooming onion while it
appears to be a normal onion each layer
of the onion is a different flavor of
Chip leading all the way into the middle
truly a gourmet snack with more layers
than well actually exactly as many
layers as an onion and what about for
those who are anomalously trapped in the
year 2012 and are looking for a snack
that is both tasty and meanworthy while
you'd be lucky to receive a 700 Yen
bacon shirt it's exactly what it says on
the can an edible shirt that both smells
and tastes like bacon and has no real
side effects other than making you smell
a little like bacon while you you're
wearing it though this could be a
dangerous anomalous effect if you decide
to walk through your local dog park
while you're wearing it we've been told
it pairs well with the meat hat Teriyaki
Fedora a size 64 Trilby style Fedora
made entirely out of Teriyaki flavored
beef jerky the object came flattened in
a cardboard box bearing the tagline you
can have your hat and eat it too which
is a pun that probably makes a lot more
sense in their Dimension still a bit
hungry well lucky for you this magical
vending machine has got you covered on
dessert too for 700 Yen the foundation
was given an entire edible chess set
with each of the ornate pieces carved
from what seem like hard Pez Style candy
it's less Checkmate and more check eight
another pun that I promise is funnier in
another dimension and for 300 Yen extra
you might walk away with a candy robot
playset these are more hard candy
components that can be put together to
create functional anomalous mini robots
that move on their own walking aimlessly
and bumping into walls but what about
the full meal craving consumer on the go
who wants both a dinner and a dessert
combined into one disgusting package
don't worry the interdimensional vending
machine has got you covered just 400 Yen
can net you some delicious Turtle these
are balls of fried turkey filled with
chocolate a smaller ball of duck more
chocolate and in the very center a small
ball of fried chicken even the labeling
on the product describes it as having
450 percent of an adult human's daily
recommended fat intake we'll leave it to
you to decide if this is a decadent
treat worthy of the gods or utterly
disgusting maybe you're feeling a little
cheeky though or you need the perfect
comedic dessert for your bachelorette
party the vending machine has a candy
direct from an alternate Korea a tasty
if slightly too sweet chocolate candy
shaped like a certain male organ filled
with we kid you not liquid White
chocolate perfect for anyone who has
both the sweet tooth and the sense of
humor of a 12 year old okay these were
definitely all weird Treats but let's
get really really strange now from the
disgusting to the confusing to the
inedible to the straight up deadly if
you're a bit of a sadist perhaps you're
the kind of person who enjoys watching
their snacks dying in front of them
before they eat them for that the
vending machine provides an aluminum box
with a viewing window and a red button
on top inside are a collection of small
furry creatures each with a single big
eye when the button is pressed the
creatures inside are abruptly
superheated cooking them all to death at
that point the Box opens and the
creatures are ready to eat we've been
told they were crunchy spicy and tasted
a little like beef maybe you're part of
the slow food movement for that we
recommend the delicious pile of slugs
which is exactly what it sounds like
this is a produce box like the kind used
for packing strawberries except it's
full of live slugs there are both
advantages and disadvantages to actually
eating these slugs the advantage is that
they contain large amounts of vitamin C
E and most of the B complex which are
all crucial to a healthy and balanced
diet the disadvantage is that they
contain large amounts of arsenic which
will kill you though of course if you
still have a candy flavored death wish
but you prefer your entomological treats
a little more leggy then may we interest
you in a fine caramelized spider for a
modest 500 yen it's full of deadly
quantities of an unknown anomalous Venom
that's pretty much impossible to cure
but it's worth it for the Sweet Sticky
goodness that comes before death sets in
another strange item dispensed by the
vending machine was a tall metal
aluminum canister with a ring pole that
upon opening had a violent chemical
reaction with the air and triggered a
large explosion apparently this
particular beverage was never intended
for oxygenated environments the blast
killed two researchers and resulted in
the temporary suspension of testing
though in a slight silver lining for
this Fiasco the testing area did smell
of citrus for a few days which the
janitors must have enjoyed as they
cleaned up all the body parts another
dangerous snack provided by the vending
machine was a long tube of chips called
Pringles not to be confused with any
other long two base chips you may be
thinking of when the tube was opened or
popped as they say the d-class that the
chips were presented to began
compulsively eating them when
researchers ordered the d-class to stop
it seemed almost as if they couldn't
regardless of the orders given to them
the d-class just kept eating even when
guards terminated the d-class there and
then the corpse continued to eat chips
out of the tube until it was physically
pried out of their hands but if all
those salty frangles had really worked
up a thirst in you perhaps you can wash
the them down with a delicious can of
Cherry Bomb an intense cherry flavored
drink dispensed by scp-261 for 450 Yen
when a d-class sampled this delicious
soda they commented on it tasting
strongly of cherry a few moments later
their head exploded with the force of a
stick of dynamite coating everyone and
everything around it in gooey head
viscera the resulting cleanup took an
arduous six hours but wow was that
cherry tasty and finally why not
complete this anomalous vending machine
Feast with a 1 000 Yen paper mache
pinata resembling a dead horse that
comes ready to use with a baseball bat
everyone who saw the pinata fell
compelled to beat it mercilessly with
the bat until candy began to fall out
many in attendance claimed that it was
the 1000th gift Unleashed by scp-261 and
thus warranted celebration once the dead
horse was thoroughly beaten all Cognito
hazardous properties ceased there
there's a joke somewhere in there but
for the life of us we're not sure we can
find it oh wow maybe it's in another
dimension someone was screaming inside
the incinerator the year was 1975. the
location was a top-secret Refinery and
waste disposal plant one of the many
front organizations owned and operated
by the SCP Foundation this sprawling
facility separated into three different
huge units each with a specialized task
was located around 75 kilometers outside
of Summer Springs Colorado it had
operated for several decades without
incident but today all hell was about to
break loose alarms were blaring in Unit
C the area of the facility that dealt
with destroying non-anomalous waste via
incineration a traumatized worker had
pulled the emergency lever near one of
the incinerators in a panic when he
first heard the loud banging against the
interior walls and then though horrific
paint whales that's when workers of Unit
C came to a horrifying realization the
screams weren't just coming from one of
the incinerators in Unit C they were
coming from all six A Chorus of absolute
agony echoing up out of the ash pits
this was impossible as far as the unit c
staff were concerned these incinerators
were only to be used for confirmed
non-anomalous material could some
animals or even some poor workers
somehow fallen into the incinerators but
even if they had what were the odds that
someone had fallen in all six of them at
once it was impossible the site director
was immediately brought in to authorize
an investigation at which point he
determined that at least one of the
furnaces in this case furnace number
four be shut off so researchers and
guards could investigate what was going
on inside it seemed like the obvious
course of action but for some of the
people on site that day this would prove
to be a fatal mistake when the fires
were put out something started rattling
in the disposal Chute there was a
scratching and squealing noise like
something scraping up against the metal
a maintenance worker was ordered to go
check inside and they opened the hatch
he let out a bone chilling shrink there
was something or was it someone climbing
back up the disposal Chute it emerged
from the darkness backlit by the still
burning embers of the incinerator
letting out an awful screeching noise
that could make even a hardened mobile
task force operative shake with fear the
creature was humanoid a charred
mutilated skeleton reaching out towards
the maintenance worker with a bony claw
before the worker had a chance to
stumble back in horror the Beast had
classed pinned by the throat and started
to squeeze it didn't even need to
strangle him the heat of its skeletal
hand burned away the worker's throat in
seconds leaving his limp wheezing body
to drop to the metal grade of the
platform below him several armed guards
and maintenance workers move forward to
fend off the monster but just then a
volley of more violent shrieks echoed
out of the shoot behind it it only took
seconds for over a dozen more creatures
to crawl out of the disposal Chute they
were all like the first people at
various stages of incineration some were
glowing charred skeletons with barely
any flesh others looking more like
severe burn victims their faces
contoured into scowls of hate and rage
the assembled guards opened fire on the
sudden influx of anomalies emptying the
magazines of their submachine guns into
their burning bodies but their weapons
didn't seem to cause any lasting damage
the bullets would tear through the Flesh
of the creatures causing some of them to
stumble and fall but the wounds would
close and the creatures would rise again
it seemed they possessed a deadly combo
of extremely high aggression and
incredible regenerative abilities none
of the staff present in Unit C were safe
as the burning corpses attacked anyone
they could find with their bare hands
beating and biting and clawing many of
them would grapple with Foundation
Personnel latching on to them and trying
to pull them back down into the
incinerator with them these creatures
that would later be known as
scp-2419-a caused several fatalities
with their surprise attack that day and
the situation was only brought back
under control when a mobile task force
that possessed more advanced training
and weaponry was dispatched to the
location despite orders from the site
director the MTF found it impossible to
actually terminate any of the entities
due to their regenerative abilities
instead the MTF agents focused on
forcing the anomalies back into the
shoot of incinerator number four using a
powerful industrial steam Lance once
they were back inside the incinerator's
burners were started up once again the
mtfs were also able to capture five of
the entities and detain them for
questioning and experimentation finally
bringing this unexpected Containment
Breach to an end the foundation is an
organization that Prides itself on
possessing forbidden and secret
knowledge but even they had no idea what
had just happened there seemed to be no
earthly explanation why these creatures
would suddenly manifest inside the
incinerators but as the detained
anomalies continued regenerating a
slightly clearer picture of what exactly
the foundation was dealing with began to
emerge every single one of the captured
anomalies kept regenerating and upon
getting to the point that they were no
longer Burns scarred the researchers
studying the anomalous creatures
discovered that each one was identical
to a deceased d-class from the
foundation's records they were
physically and genetically identical to
the dead class D Personnel perfect
copies save for the fact that their sole
mission in life seemed to now be pure
and unmitigated aggression and violence
researchers wanted to gain greater
insight into the minds of these strange
creatures through the use of extensive
psychological evaluations and interviews
it would turn out to be a very dangerous
investigation a psychological researcher
by the name of Dr Warren conducted an
interview with one of the
scp-2419a instances in hopes of better
understanding their mindset this
creature had been heard laughing not
long before the interview began so it
wasn't an unreasonable assumption to
believe that it could be capable of
speech the interviewee was separated
from Dr Warren by a thick pane of glass
to prevent it from indulging in any of
its more violent urges the problem was
that Dr Warren and his assistant
researchers had severely underestimated
what these creatures were capable of
doing to get what they wanted Dr Warren
tried to begin the interview in good
faith he spoke calmly and politely to
the creature through the glass
attempting to remind it of the person it
once was the anomaly didn't appear to be
paying attention to the doctor though
instead focusing on pulling its own arm
apart and breaking the bones within Dr
Warren began to think that the creatures
weren't even sentient if the only
activity they seem to engage in was The
Wonton destruction of themselves and
others but underestimating them like
this proved to be a big mistake by
removing the skin off of its arm and
whittling its bone down to Sharp edges
the anomaly had transformed its arm into
a makeshift knife before anyone realized
this it had already used its own Jagged
bones to break the glass divider and
attack Dr Warren be perished not long
after after being stabbed multiple times
in his face and eyes and the anomaly was
forcefully taken back to its holding
cell Dr Daniel Jennings a senior
researcher was then put on the case he
released a chilling memo of the
creatures after his observation period
ended it read before I came here I
worked as a prison shrink every person
you met had a story bursting with pain
and sorrow sometimes these stories were
about the pain they suffered sometimes
it was about the pain they inflicted
some days you felt like everyone there
was a beautiful soul toned down by their
circumstances other days you'd find out
what some of them did and a part of you
was glad that they were there to suffer
for it but at the end of every day I
always told myself they're all humans
they're all people they all deserve the
same dignity respect and love as
everyone else no exceptions Dr Jennings
goes on I opened up with that anecdote
only so that you could understand that
what I'm about to say is not said
lightly these things are not people they
are people shaped monsters they are well
beyond any definition of psychopathy
everything they do they do to hurt maim
and kill I would pity them but that
would imply that they're worth pitying
put them in a hole then fill that hole
with concrete better still throw them
back into the incinerator where you
found them I doubt they'll even care
following this string of unfortunate
incidents containment procedures were
put into place to hopefully prevent
anything that had happened to The
Unlucky Foundation staff from happening
again the entire facility was fenced off
and was constantly patrolled by MTF beta
7 also known as the Maz Hatters a group
specializing in containing anomalies
which present powerful biological
chemical or radiological dangers the
furnaces that the anomalous creatures
emerge from remain lit at all times with
workers checking and carrying out
maintenance on every single one each day
of the week outside of this the facility
is essentially a no-go Zone reinforced
steel hatches cover the shoots and they
are to Forever remain bolted shut all
because of that one terrifying day in
1975. that was the day that the summer
springs waste disposal facility which
had been a valuable asset to the
foundation for decades instead became
classified as the euclid-class anomaly
scp-2419 it is not uncommon for a
foundation asset to One Day become a
dangerous anomaly requiring containment
but the same question always pops up
after why what had a place that had been
so valuable to the foundation suddenly
become such an active danger the answer
as is often the case is contained within
the question why would a waste disposal
plan be so important to the foundation
in the first place and more importantly
what else was going on at the plan to
make it such an area of active
importance for one of the most powerful
organizations in the entire world to put
it simply the plant allowed the
foundation to dispose of something far
more important than mere waste material
it gave them what they needed to better
erase memories as you probably already
know the foundation makes liberal use of
amnestics on those exposed to anomalous
material to make them forget what they
had seen and experienced but these
elusive chemicals many of which are
sourced from scp-3000 are an inexact
science however at the summer Springs
Waste Disposal plant researchers
discovered an immensely valuable
alternative much of what was disposed of
in the incinerators of Unit C were the
bodies of dead d-class Personnel before
being burned autopsies were performed on
the bodies to make sure they were
non-anomalous including the brain back
in the 1960s while performing research
on the brains of dead d-classes they
found a method of extracting and
Distilling the positive memories of the
Dead creating a kind of happy soup when
administered into someone who has
undergone amnestic treatment this happy
soup creates positive false memories in
their mind that fills in those pesky
blank spaces that are often behind this
was so useful that happy memories were
extracted from the minds of every single
d-class core that pass through Unit C
totaling well into the thousands by the
time that the first
scp-2419a instances began to rise but as
all Happiness joy and love were removed
from the minds of the d-classes it
seemed that all that was left was pure
hate pain violence and fury feelings too
intense and evil to destroy these were
bodies imbued with a malice so powerful
that no fire could ever burn them away
they exist now with single-minded
determination to get out and destroy
everything around them everything
including the ones that made them the
SCP Foundation itself and in the end
it's only a matter of time until they
get out there are thousands of them in
there unable to die unable to stop the
only thing keeping them in there is the
constant burning of the furnaces around
them and those furnaces can't burn
forever the monsters lurking in scp-2419
will outlive the fire that surrounds
them because while the furnaces they are
contained in are hot the fires of hate
that burn within scp-2419 entities are
even more powerful and they know this
they know they can't be contained
forever and that someday soon they'll be
able to emerge and exact their terrible
Revenge those who must walk past the
incinerators may think they hear their
screams echoing out from within but it's
not screaming at all it's laughter as we
all know the SCP Foundation secures
contains and protects the various
anomalies under its custody but their
mission isn't limited to just grabbing
the object and chucking it into a
containment Locker at the bottom of a
classified site deep below the surface
of the Earth the foundation wants to get
a comprehensive full understanding of
all the strange items creatures and
humanoids in its kind
because that's the only way to
understand what they're capable of what
danger they pose and how to effectively
contain them that much is logical but
the problem is that there's no Global
scientific Community surrounding
anomalies at least not ones willing to
cooperate with the foundation perhaps
the chaos Insurgency or Global occult
Coalition have some scientists who have
studied anomalies or the various
government agencies that know about the
anomalous world like the unusual
incidence unit or Soviet grup but for
the most part the foundation is utterly
alone when it comes to figuring out how
these anomalies work what they are and
how to combat them so the foundation
does what any institution would do
experiments many of the foundation's
most important and iconic anomalies are
defined by the experiments the
white-coated scientists have performed
on them sometimes even using human
subjects through the notorious and
Infamous d-class program everyone knows
about how scp-682 the hard to destroy
lizard has been subjected to practically
every known weapon and attack Under the
Sun in an attempt to kill the highly
dangerous hateful predator and who can
forget scp-914 the Clockworks and the
countless objects the foundation has put
through it on its five settings to see
what it spits out needless to say the
foundation's experiments are incredibly
important to how the organization
functions so those scps that can offer
lots of testing options are very
treasured and prized along with being
iconic and legendary throughout the
foundation today we're going to be
looking at one such anomaly but not a
dangerous hostile man-eating Predator
like scp-682 or a mysterious Eldritch
machine like scp-914 now today we're
going to be looking at something much
more simpler than that a coffee machine
yes today we're going to be inspecting
scp-294 affectionately referred to by
guards personnel as the coffee machine
though you probably don't want to order
a hot cup of joe in this coffee machine
lest you well let's not get ahead of
ourselves the first thing you see when
you open the scp-294 file is its number
of course item 294 object class Euclid
the next thing you see is the image if
you were imagining a tiny little coffee
maker before this should get rid of that
scp-294 is big the kind of coffee
machine you'd see in a factory break
room it's almost the size of a vending
machine and has a big colored window
showing a few cups of coffee along with
the slots for cash and coins so drinkers
can pay for their espressos but the most
notable feature on scp-294 is the full
keyboard on the front panel it's a
typical qwerty keyboard just like yours
with a space bar and everything why on
Earth would a coffee machine need a
keyboard the special containment
procedures paint an interesting picture
by which we mean there aren't any
scp-294 doesn't need any special
procedures secret rituals or complex
machines to keep it contained but it's
still Euclid so only Personnel who have
security clearance of level 2 or higher
are allowed to interact with it at the
moment this is surprising when you
realize that scp-294 is currently being
held not an anomalous item Locker or
containment cell but exactly where you'd
expect to find a big coffee machine a
break room specifically the site 19
second floor Personnel break room but
it's not alone it's monitored by two
guards with level 3 clearance around the
clock for them sitting in the break room
all day guarding a coffee machine that
can't move and is too heavy to lift has
to be a pretty sweet gig considering
what other kinds of jobs are available
at the foundation but all that raises
even more Mysteries what the heck is up
with this coffee machine the description
starts off obvious enough affirm that
yes scp-200 94 is indeed a standard
coffee vending machine but with the
difference we all noticed earlier
instead of a simple button list of
options it has a full keyboard on it
each button aligning with the letter on
a real keyboard and when someone slips
50 cents into the coin slot quite a
bargain for coffee if you ask me the
user gets a message on screen prompting
them to enter the name of what liquid
they'd like you type it in on the
keyboard and that's that the machine
drops a little paper cup and a nozzle
shoots out 12 fluid ounces of whatever
you requested pretty nifty isn't it but
it gets niftier most people would only
think to ask a coffee machine for well
coffee but scp-294 accepts any liquid
and some things that aren't liquids when
the foundation initially got their hands
on it they ran no less than 97 tests on
it after they realized they weren't just
limited to espressos and cappuccinos at
first any kind of liquid you could drink
was requested the researchers popped in
requests for water coffee Beer soda
milkshakes and out they came then they
decided to get a little more creative
they started to request things you
couldn't possibly drink not if you
wanted to stay alive sulfuric and
hydrochloric acid like the kind scp-682
is suspended in wiper fluid motor oil
but scp-294 stubbornly provided even if
the liquids would melt through the
researchers throats like a knife through
butter then the researchers decided to
apply some of their scientific knowledge
there are a lot of chemical compounds
that don't usually exist in a liquid
state on planet Earth's surface they
typed in nitrogen iron and glass among
others and received shimmering liquids
and paper cups they sent them off to a
lab for analysis and wouldn't you know
it chemically identical to nitrogen iron
and glass but when they typed in Diamond
no doubt wondering whether they'd found
an infinite Cash Cow they received an
error message on this screen it seemed
that while scp-294 could deliver
substances that aren't usually in a
liquid state on Earth's surface it
needed to be at least possible for the
substance to be in a pure liquid form
for scp-294 to dispense it since diamond
is only a mineral it couldn't be
dispensed then they tried to test
something else and got a slightly
disturbing response on the small LCD
display out of stock it stopped
responding to requests for over an hour
then made a small noise and began to
accept requests again it appears that
the machine can take about 50 requests
before needing to take an hour and a
half to restock itself and while only
the machine is anomalous the small 12
ounce paper cups it dispenses its
liquids in seems remarkably Hardy
substances that would have eaten through
paper instantly like these sulfuric acid
and hydrochloric acid had no effect on
these little cups though the same can be
said for those that drank from them one
of the researchers had a great idea here
was an anomaly that was practically
harmless and could be a great little way
for the foundation to scale back its
budget a little bit they proposed
putting scp-294 into the break room it
currently resides in both two more
easily conduct experiments and to save
money when agents and doctors came in
for lunch and needed a quick drink or in
the mornings where everyone was looking
for coffee to wake them up with no good
reason not to the machine was put in the
break room but not long after an
unfortunate incident occurred one with
enough harm that it was deemed necessary
that only personnel with security
clearance interact with scp-294 what
could have happened to cause this did
someone burn themselves on hot coffee
did the vending machine accidentally
Crush someone no the reality is much
darker one morning in August of 2005
agent Joseph whose full name has been
redacted to preserve their identity one
up to the vending machine in the break
room looking to get a hot cup of coffee
to wake himself up between shifts
another agent in the room who was on
break at the time saw him and made a
suggestion to find out what scp-294
would do when given the colloquial name
rather than the exact real name of a
drink they just wanted to see what would
happen so agent Joseph slipped in two
quarters and typed in a hot cup of joe
seconds after he began sweating like a
pig he was feeling very hot even though
the break room was fully air conditioned
and his skin began to flush he then
clutched his head complaining that he
was dizzy and the whole room was
spinning around before collapsing to the
floor the other agent immediately called
the medical staff who Moved agent Joseph
to the infirmary and stabilized him once
they made sure he wasn't in any real
trouble they also grabbed whatever
scp-294 had spit out it was a disgusting
thick reddish brown liquid with a strong
stench and when they ran the labs on it
they confirmed it was exactly what they
thought it was a mixture of blood tissue
bone marrow cerebrospinal fluid and
other bodily fluids that was an exact
DNA match for agent Joseph
scp-294 somehow managed to literally
liquefy 12 ounces from the agent's body
before producing them into a cup this
offered a clue maybe it stole the
liquids it was asked for from the
nearest source in any case the agent was
released after a few weeks of bed rest
and care to make sure he wasn't further
injured and both involved agents were
reprimanded with the knowledge of how
accidentally dangerous scp-294 can be
who can blame the foundation for wanting
to keep a careful lid on it researchers
were curious though and received
clearance to test the scp's abilities to
retrieve specific liquids from long
distances with an o5's approval and
oversight they input a cup of
scp-075's secretion
scp-075 the corrosive snail is exactly
what it sounds like a gross little
creature that secretes a highly Caustic
Acid capable of melting almost anything
without fail the coffee machine dispends
the secretion into the cup and the cup
stayed perfectly intact but at the very
same time in scp-075 cell the creature
woke up and began secreting acid that
immediately disappeared all in all about
12 ounces the same amount in the cup
based off these results further testing
with scp-294 was approved one researcher
tried punching in a request for a cup of
gold what came out was a small paper cup
of molten gold that quickly cooled to
room temperature asking for cups of
silver and platinum produce similar
results but based off of previous tests
it seemed clear that the machine wasn't
creating precious metals so much as
siphoning them off from somewhere else
the next request was a strange one a cup
of anti-water the machine took a moment
then printed a small message on its LCD
display out of range this confirmed that
the machine couldn't produce substances
that didn't actually exist and couldn't
break physics to get its materials by
peering into alternate universes
Dimensions or realities after that the
researchers tested for diamond and got
the result that you already know of and
out of range error some more
investigations showed that all solid
substances that don't have a liquid form
get this error but asking for a cup of
liquid carbon produced exactly that
because liquid carbon isn't the same
thing as a diamond though both are made
of carbon
scp-294 clearly has more knowledge of
chemistry than some of us then the
researchers created an entirely new
drink made of bleach various sodas
protein powders and spices they blended
it together and put it in a jar across
the room from scp-290 4 when requested
the amount of the liquid in the cup was
missing from the jar proving that
scp-294 doesn't actually create its own
liquids but how does scp-294 react when
presented with a more subjective request
one researcher asked for the best drink
I've ever had after a moment the paper
cup filled with something that looked
like Cola but the researcher said it
tasted like a drink he had years ago at
a party and that he'd always remembered
as his favorite drink though he couldn't
say what was in it but that was a
subjective test and the researchers
repeated it with a different subject
when an agent also requested the best
drink I've ever had the machine produced
a simple Vienna lager with a label
showing a group of people drinking it at
the beach and no brand name the agent
confirmed that the best drink he ever
had was a Vienna lager at the beach with
his friends so scp-294 could not only
read people's minds it can read memories
they don't even know they still have
another one they tried was something
Cassie will like referencing
scp-085 the young girl who lived in a
drawn on world the cup dispensed was
completely empty but it had a small
drawing printed on the side of a soda
glass with brown and white things
floating on top of each other the
researchers presented the cup to Cassie
and were told by her it was a chocolate
banana milkshake and a delicious one at
that a cup of music was a strange
request and produced an even stranger
result a clear odorless carbonated drink
that tasted vaguely alcoholic when drunk
subjects said they could feel it and
started showing an affinity to music
being able to sing and dance to a rhythm
when they had no sense of Rhythm or were
tone deaf before whether scp-294 can
produce even more abstract Concepts is
still under study but was interrupted by
the next test an unfortunate Containment
Breach incident at site 19 left several
Personnel trapped in the break room
heavily injured while mtfs fought to
re-establish control over the site an
agent typed in a cup of medical
knowledge and the Machine quickly
produced a green liquid after drinking
it the agent was able to treat the
injuries of their fellow Personnel
consistent with standard first responder
practices and was commended for The
Bravery but their knowledge didn't stick
around after the breach and attempts to
recreate the liquid failed they decided
that scp-294 broke its own rules for
self-preservation in the emergency
implying that it's not only sentient it
is intelligent a doctor using scp-294
made a request close to him my life
story while nowhere close to a drink
scp-294 seemed to accept the input until
it started shaking violently and making
odd noises it remained in this new state
for about three minutes then returned to
normal spitting out a completely opaque
black fluid like tar in a cop despite
the strange reaction the doctor drank
the fluid and immediately informed the
others he was now able to remember
everything that had ever happened to him
from the smallest childhood event to the
most important events in his adult life
he excused himself and disappeared into
his office the next time the staff saw
him two days later he was carrying an
autobiography 600 pages long then the
researchers decided to try their luck
and input surprise me the resulting
solution was a cup containing What
seemed to be regular water right until a
researcher touched it it was just water
all right but it had been superheated to
200 degrees Celsius while remaining in
liquid form the moment someone touched
it bang it violently evaporated into
steam spraying boiling water everywhere
not only does scp-294 have intelligence
it has a sense of humor albeit a quite
rude one the next three requests were
for blood namely blood of the Smilodon
or saber-toothed tiger of the passenger
pigeon and a Founding Father Thomas
Jefferson but the only thing scp-294
produced were out of range errors
confirming it can't take liquids that
don't exist anymore but in the next test
blood was received from wolves saliva
was received from horses urine was
received from koalas and cerebral spinal
fluid was received from foibromus
pattersoni a rodent that went extinct
some 8 million years ago though if
scp-294 is working according to its own
rules it means that there may be still
one in the wild somehow for the next
test the researchers decided to get back
to the scientific roots of it all they
made a request for a cup of
d-151839s leukemia knowing that the
d-class in question had a very Advanced
case of cancer the machine outputted it
without any trouble and Analysis of the
liquid showed it contained cancer cells
that match the d-class's DNA but another
request for the same spat out and out of
range error what's more a medical
checkup on the d-class revealed that
their tumor was completely gone but
unfortunately it was only a short-term
fix the cancer cells recurred within two
weeks of the test
scp-294 initially just seemed like a
boring magic vending machine but it was
only after the extensive experimentation
that you just saw a shortened log of
that the SCP Foundation was able to
discern its true nature it wasn't an
unthinking object it was sentient
intelligent and even a little sarcastic
though none of that stopped it from
doing its job providing people with a
hot cup of whatever they needed to drink
just make sure you type in your request
very carefully an SCP Foundation
researcher is monitoring the salt
content of a large tank filled with
water inside the tank just under the
surface is a huge mass of rusted metal
though few pieces have a couple specks
of their original shiny surface visible
through the dark red exterior the
researcher suddenly looks up from his
task though does anyone else hear that
noise it's a terrible noise like metal
scraping and scratching against each
other but the Heap of metal in the tank
isn't moving still the noises continue
though and the researcher keeps staring
at the unmoving hunk of metal in the
tank all he can think about is diving in
and letting his body become a part of it
kept submerged in a big saltwater tank
at the SCP Foundation is an object but
perhaps a more accurate way to describe
it would be as a machine referred to as
scp-882 the machines containment tank is
required according to containment
procedures to be filled with at least 40
percent pure sea water direct from the
ocean if at any point the rusty surface
of scp-882 begins to show signs of
becoming more like shiny metal than the
percentage of sea water must be raised
to 100 percent until the metal is
complete covered in Rust trying to keep
metal rusted that might sound like a
strange concept but you'll see why it's
so necessary soon
scp-882 looks like little more than a
collection of seemingly random pieces of
metal all fused together as if they had
been welded gears cables pulleys screws
and belts all different shapes and sizes
all made of different Metals all of
these various components do not appear
to be uniform or have been made to fit
each other and are instead all stuck
together in one big unstructured mass of
metal objects but scp-882 wasn't built
to be like this instead this seems to be
the result of one of
scp-882's latent anomalous properties
the absorption of metal any metal that
comes into contact with scp-882 will
become permanently attached to it and
after a few days will be a new part of
scp-882 that means that any metal that
touches that peace will also become a
part of scp-882 and on and on because of
this strange property absolutely no
metal is allowed to be brought near
scp-882 and only organic materials are
permitted to come into direct contact
with it that includes using non-metal
alternatives to keep the machine
securely contained
scp-882 is suspended in its salt water
tank by organic cotton fiber lines which
also require changing on a daily basis
any and all researchers that the SCP
Foundation has interacting with the
metallic Mass are required to wear thick
cotton gloves at all times you might
think that this sounds pretty easy to
contain just don't let it touch metal no
problem organic materials only no
removal rust Allowed no sweat the
foundation staff working with 882
probably felt the same way until they
started hearing
scp-882 make noise while scp-882 is
usually silent personnel let's spend an
extended period of time close to the
machine have reported intense grinding
or clicking noises coming from somewhere
in the mess of metal components while
they start out low and are almost
unnoticeable these sounds get gradually
louder until eventually they become
completely unbearable for human beings
to withstand so then why don't these
sounds show up on audio recordings
because the grinding or clicking noises
from
scp-882-r and actually extreme auditory
hallucinations but even though they
aren't real these sounds are more than
capable of driving anyone who hears them
into a state of psychosis and here's
where things get tricky the only way to
make the noises stop is to offer scp-882
more metal as mentioned any object that
is made of any type of metal that comes
into contact with the machine becomes a
part of its mass allowing new objects to
become fused to the surface of scp-882
will cause the grinding noises to side
but will increase
scp-882's Mass permanently if the noises
aren't stopped though then the mental
state of those afflicted by them only
grows worse and some victims of
scp-882's auditory hallucinations have
gone so far as to throw themselves into
the tank containing it where they were
killed almost immediately their bodies
crushed to death by anomalous forces and
becoming unrecoverable from the tangle
of gears and random metal objects the
SCP Foundation now requires any of its
Personnel that work directly with
scp-882 to report any instances of noise
coming from the machine additionally
whoever reports hearing strange sounds
in the vicinity of scp-882 must turn
themselves in for a full psychological
evaluation depending on the results the
researcher will either be free to return
to their work or will face containment
themselves at an undisclosed Foundation
facility the surface of scp-882 exhibits
an extreme resistance to damage
according to the foundation's testing
the metal structure has a tensile
strength and toughness stronger than
aircraft-grade titanium alloy despite
this the machine still seems to be
constructed of weaker metals like tin
iron gold and many others still yet to
be identified it takes extreme heat and
several hours of exposure at that to cut
even the smallest portion of metal from
the main bulk of scp-882 but where did
it come from the SCP Foundation First
recovered scp-882 near an island
commonly on the northeast coast of banks
Island one of the larger islands in the
Canadian Arctic archipelago strangely
not a single scrap of metal not even
underground metallic ore was found
within a one mile radius of where the
machine was discovered stranger still
the small town located nearby seemed to
be abandoned with signs that it had been
devoid of any human life for quite a
number of years the collection of fused
metal components later are designated
scp-882 was found submerged in seawater
the machine was coated in Rust and the
foundation has chosen to keep it in the
same Rusty state it has been kept in
since its containment why because when
Foundation Personnel first attempted to
remove
scp-882 from the water and the rust
began to flake away from scp-882's metal
surface its gears and cogs started to
turn Foundation Personnel on site were
unsure of what the machine's purpose was
but wanted to Halt it in case it proved
deadly the number of ill-fated attempts
at containment occurred soon after with
any person getting too close to scp-882
finding themselves pulled into its mass
and crushed to death between turning
cogs after multiple accidents that
resulted in the demise of foundation
Personnel Dr Charles gears authorized
the use of
scp-2519 to help stop the movement of
scp-882's gears scp-25 519 is an audio
file titled Babylon mp3 which features
the song By the Waters of Babylon by
Philip Hayes and text from the biblical
Psalm 137 playing this file can cause
malfunctions to occur in various
electronic and Mechanical Devices
normally reducing the speed at which
they can operate or causing a complete
cessation of a machine's function in
scp-882's case the sound of Babylon mp3
successfully slowed The Machine's moving
Parts allowing Foundation Personnel to
safely get closer to it teams then cut
the massive metal down to a more
manageable size with extreme heat and it
was finally contained however another
question arises surely if scp-882 is a
machine then it must have a purpose
right and perhaps more importantly what
is its connection to the infamous
machine loving group of Interest the
Church of the broken God both of these
questions might just have one easy
answer to put it plain and simple
scp-882 may just be the heart of the
broken God the Church of the broken God
is a religious organization that the SCP
Foundation has had a number of
encounters with over the years members
of the church share in the belief that
life specifically biological flesh-based
life is inherently wrong even evil this
group worships mechanization the process
of making something or someone more
mechanical in nature according to the
beliefs of the church there were two
gods yaldaboth and McCain who created
Humanity together yaldabath was the god
of Flesh and animal Instinct granting
humans their bodies while meccane the
God of machine and intellect bless man
with the power of free thought as
humankind developed and its civilization
began building machines yaldaboth became
enraged that they were ignoring the
instincts she had bestowed upon them she
endeavored to destroy the creations of
man in an attempt to revert them to the
animals she had intended to be as Legend
goes McCain acted as Humanity's Savior
and intervened to stop yaldabov they got
a machine shattered himself transforming
his body into a number of pieces to form
a cage for his fellow God fragments of
mechan rained down on planet Earth
fragments that the Church of the broken
God believes it is their duty to recover
however a number of these pieces are
cataloged to scps that the foundation is
either aware of or has in containment
they are scp-882 or his broken heart to
the church
scp-271 his broken gift
scp-813 his Broken Eyes
scp-1139 his broken tongue
scp-635 has broken mind and finally his
broken blood which refers to
scp-217 often using anomalous technology
members of the Church of the broken God
intend to uncover or steal these various
components the church's ultimate goal is
to bring the correct pieces to together
and completely restore McCain's form it
is their hope that he will guide them to
intellectual Enlightenment and bless
them with new mechanical forms so that
they can discard their current Flesh and
Blood bodies however the foundation and
the church are certainly not the only
groups to have a fascination with
scp-882 near the banks Island site where
the machine was first discovered
Foundation Personnel encountered a man
the sole survivor of the nearby town
this individual by the name of Richard
Wright was apprehended and brought in
for questioning with Dr gears during
their interview Richard revealed a
number of details about the townsfolk
who had first uncovered
scp-882 and what ultimately became of
them according to his account the
community formed a cult around
scp-882 after a man named Alan found it
the machine's Parts had begun to turn
and move but with no clear indication as
to what was powering it soon a local
priest Father Pat also took an interest
in scp-882 both he and Alan seemed to
share the belief that the machine had
been built by God for a higher purpose
and encouraged residents of the nearby
town to come and offer metal to it
Richard explained that the locals were
plagued by the auditory hallucinations
typical of long-term exposure to scp-882
kept awake at all hours of the Night by
clanking grinding and the screaming of
metal before long Richard noticed more
and more metal items being fed to the
machine with many local residents
content to just sit and stare at the
mass he also noticed that Father Pat and
Alan both seemed to be acting strangely
around the machine insisting that all
the metal that had been added to it
still wasn't enough then one night
during a communion before
scp-882 Father Pat took a pair of pliers
and began tearing out townspeople's
metal fillings Richard watched in horror
as the priest wrenched teeth from the
mouths of ordinary people and threw them
into a CPA 882 but still claiming it
wasn't enough then he turned on Allen
accusing him of hiding metal from the
great machine inside his body the
townsfolk turned on Alan the first one
to find
scp-882 and threw him and his metal hip
into the machine his body breaking under
its moving Parts luckily scp-882 remains
contained at least for now until the
members of the Church of the broken God
find a way to reunite the heart of their
god with the other pieces of its
scattered body and meccane can Rise
Again an outcome that his worshipers are
eager to bring to fruition sooner rather
than later did you ever have to perform
a dissection in school maybe you had to
carve up a fetal pig or slice into a
frog while nightmarish visions of Kermit
and a widowed Miss Piggy danced in your
head though it's rarely a pleasant
experience unless your tastes are on The
Morbid side most biology teachers would
agree that the best way to learn how
some something works is to take it apart
as distasteful as it can be to hold a
frog's tiny liver in your hands it
definitely does give you a better sense
of the pieces that make up the complete
creature but what if there was an easier
way to look at the individual parts of a
living being what if you could take it
apart without ever having to prep a
scalpel or stain your hands with the
blood of innocent frogs like most of the
seemingly impossible things in our world
the SCP Foundation discovered something
that allows its users to do just that in
fact it can handle a lot more than just
a frog and its applications go far
beyond the confines of a high school
science lab
scp-291 is a small plane steel building
with a large door on one side the door
has no handle or knob and functions
similarly to a garage door the door
cannot be pried open by any ordinary
means and the inside of scp-291 can only
be accessed if the structure is
connected to a suitable power source
once a power source has been connected
the door races and exposes a room inside
it is small about four by two meters it
contains a console board a large screen
and a Plexiglas container resembling a
coffin how very Sinister the coffin is
large enough to contain a human under
seven feet tall so sorry Ferdinand the
cannibal you're going to need to sit
this one out the coffin sits on a
conveyor belt with several tubes
connected to the wall above it on the
opposite side of the room there are
holes of varying sizes each containing a
small door that can be opened or closed
because initial observation indicated
that scp-291 was intended for some kind
of human testing a d-class test subject
was selected for experimentation the
subject was instructed to lie down in
the coffin and wait to see what would
happen next the display screen lit up
depicting a grid lined image of the test
subject buttons along the console board
adjusted the image showing the skin
muscles and organ systems of the person
in the coffin there were no words or
numbers on the screen and all of the
buttons appeared to have only two
settings on and off when one of the
researchers pressed the first button on
the console the tubes above the coffin
began pouring a blue liquid into it the
test subject reacted with confusion but
did not experience any adverse effects
they quickly lost Consciousness
indicating that the liquid was some sort
of sedative the liquid continued to pour
into the coffin until the vessel was
completely filled at which point it
congealed into a thick gel the test
subject's breathing and heartbeat slowed
to a stop and the conveyor belt suddenly
creaked to life the coffin was carried
test subject inside through a small door
that immediately locked behind it the
small room was filled with the sounds of
Gears turning Machinery clinking and
Motors worrying the display screen was
taken over by a large rectangle
resembling a traditional loading screen
after 30 minutes the process was
complete and the back door of the room
unlocked itself when the researcher
walked through the the back door they
found another room with a conveyor belt
and a row of two dozen lockers each
Locker was open one at a time and its
contents removed for examination inside
each the research team found a different
portion of the test subject's body in a
block of some unidentified clear
substance the body was divided in the
lockers into these separate parts brain
lungs and diaphragm heart digestive
system reproductive organs left eye
right eye upper left torso and arm upper
right torso and arm lower left torso and
upper leg lower right torso and upper
leg lower left leg and foot lower right
leg and foot lower left arm and hand
lower right arm and hand neck and head
upper skeletal system lower skeletal
system lymphatic and circulatory system
and skin
the miracle of the human body right
boundless in its fascinating
complexities each block of body parts
was placed back in its designated locker
and the second button on the cons Soul
was pressed at this point the doors to
the organ lockers sealed themselves shut
and the sound of the Machinery working
filled the small space once again this
continued for a duration of
approximately 45 minutes when the
Machinery went silent a new Plexiglas
coffin emerged into the main room with
the test subject inside he looked
identical to how he had looked at the
start of the experiment with no evidence
that he had previously been disassembled
the blue liquid slowly evaporated from
the container and the test subject
opened his eyes the lead researcher
conducted an immediate interview with
the reassembled subject who reported no
memory of the process after initial
exposure to the blue liquid they
insisted that the process had been like
a good night's sleep which honestly
makes us pretty eager to take it for a
spin a medical examination determined
that there were only a few changes to
the test subject during the disassembly
and reassembly when they returned to
Consciousness the test subject's stomach
was empty they were naked and all of
their hair was on with this new
understanding of scp-291's anomalous
properties the foundation decided to
continue their experimentation with each
new test the experiments became more
creative and unsurprisingly more
depraved first a d-class subject was
placed in the coffin and disassembled
then instead of placing the various body
parts in their designated lockers the
vital organs were removed from their
storage before reassembly was attempted
this resulted in the equipment shutting
down completely a researcher pressed the
third button which forced a hard reset
of the entire process causing all the
blocks of body parts to eject via an
exit hatch during the next experiment
non-vital organs were removed before the
subject's body was reassembled the
appendix and gallbladder were left out
and when the subject regained
Consciousness these organs were still
gone however there was no visible damage
or scar tissue in their place they were
simply gone as if they have never been
there in the first place so if body
parts could be move from a test subject
could new body parts be added could
existing body parts be replaced with
different ones a d-class subject in need
of a skin graft following a
flamethrower-based accident was placed
in scp-291 once taken apart a portion of
healthy skin donated by another somewhat
unwilling d-class subject was placed in
the locker along with the skin already
present there once the subject was put
back together the healthy skin had
replaced the damaged skin with no
adverse effects repeat attempts at this
test showed that it was effective for
limb transplants heart transplants and
kidney transplants with a zero percent
failure rate across all tests after
determining that scp-291 could be used
for an Untold amount of good making
organ donations easier and safer than
ever the foundation naturally had to
Pivot to something more useless but
interesting and likely horrifying after
all it's not like they could ever just
make anomalous technology available to
the public right two d-class subject sex
one man and one woman were disassembled
by scp-291 the brains of the test
subjects were swapped and then they were
reassembled when they awoke the subjects
had the personalities and memories of
the brain placed in their body in a turn
of events previously only seen in
blockbuster comedies like Freaky Friday
and the live-action Scooby-Doo movie
seminal piece of Cinema the subjects had
swapped bodies they were subsequently
disassembled their request to look at
their new bodies naked having been
swiftly denied and the brains were
returned to their rightful bodies after
the experiment was finished the subjects
appeared mostly normal however they did
complain of disorientation as well as
mental and physical discomfort over the
next several days after going through
two brain transplants in one day though
that's really the least you can expect
after perfecting the practice of
swapping body parts between different
human subjects the ghoulishly Curious
research team decided to take things in
an inter-species Direction a variety of
test subjects including cats dogs
lizards fish mice and of course humans
were selected for this next round of
experiments 20 tests were performed
using these new subjects and only three
of the experiments were successful in
transferring body parts from an animal
of one species to another animal of a
different one attempts to swap body
parts between mammals and reptiles or
fish proved disastrous when a fish and a
human were both disassembled and the
fish's gills were placed with the
human's body parts neither creature
survived the reassembly process the
human awoke with a new set of gills
embedded in their neck and immediately
began gasping for the oxygen they could
not take in within minutes they had
suffocated the fish's fate was even
worse it did not reassemble so much as
it became a pile of goo scales and two
floating eyeballs experimentation with a
human and a lizard yielded similar
results turning the lizard into a puddle
of organic matter and killing the human
test subject after only a few minutes as
disastrous as the failed cross species
tests were the successful ones were
almost as bad trial 001 involved a cat
and a human not wanting to attempt too
much at once the research team opted to
just swap out one organ the left eye
both subjects survived the transfer and
were able to use their new eye the human
subject reported full use of the cat's
eye with improved night vision in
addition to trouble seeing color the cat
did not enjoy its new eye nearly as much
as the human subject and had clawed its
human eye out of its head by the end of
the following week in trial 007 a
successful brain transfer was performed
between an adult human man and an
English Mastiff the man in the Mastiff's
body expressed discomfort with walking
on all fours and asked to be returned to
his body as soon as possible the mastiff
in the man's body adjusted to bipedal
locomotion in a few hours but was
disassembled after urinating on a
researcher's shoes the final successful
trial and the most unnerving was trial
01 one sex a female d-class test
subject's reproductive organs were
swapped with those of a pregnant
Labrador Retriever an ultrasound
conducted after the transfer indicated
that the labrador fetuses survived the
procedure and could conceivably be
carried to term by the human subject
several members of the research team
began to take bets on whether or not she
would end up giving birth to puppies but
the transfer was reversed within the day
so we'll never know what exactly would
have happened perhaps that's for the
best personally we hope the foundation's
Ethics Committee gives some of these
scientists a very Stern talking to about
their behavior on this one when not in
use for testing
scp-291 is to be disconnected from any
power sources at least two Personnel are
positioned outside of its containment at
all times standing guard and these
personnel must be swapped out every week
when it is not connected to any power
sources scp-291 is considered harmless
though it should still be treated with
caution the main entryway remains closed
and locked when there is no available
power source but the door can be opened
manually from the inside in the event of
an emergency any disassembled organisms
are stored in a locker in the
containment facility labeled with a
sharpie marker in order to keep track of
what specimens are stored there whether
this is the same Sharpie used to label
food in the break room fridge is unknown
but just like Dr D Romero's ham sandwich
it's best to leave these items untouched
any Personnel found to be responsible
for missing specimens will be
transferred to another project and
receive a strongly worded email who
Among Us hasn't wondered what happens
after our lives have come to their
inevitable ending and we play out our
final moments in the land of the living
the concept of what happens to us after
we've died has baffled scientists and
philosophers the world over for almost
as long as human civilization has
existed some out there already claim to
know the exact answer you probably
already know that the belief in the
existence of an afterlife is one hell by
almost every single religion and culture
around the globe Heaven hell Valhalla
Purgatory limbo chill the world to come
descriptions of the afterlife and how to
get sent there often varies depending on
the religion or cultural group it is
linked to but to think in more general
terms the concept usually revolves
around the soul leaving the body after
death and living forever in Eternal
Paradise that is of course unless you've
committed any deadly sins during your
lifetime if the myths are to be believed
these normally result in you being sent
down to spend eternity in damnation and
endless punishment instead of paradise
sadly there's no way to prove if any of
the various afterlives actually exist by
their very nature these afterlives exist
separate from the real physical world
that we live in while we are still alive
while we're here on Earth we can only
observe what we see happening to a body
after death and what we assume or
believe the afterlife might be like
after all it's not like any deceased
person can tell us what being dead is
like while not under the normal
circumstances anyway with no proof of
the afterlife's existence we do
unfortunately get left with the Bleak
and existentially terrifying assumption
that when we die there is nothing
waiting for us on the other side what if
there is no light at the end of the
tunnel no Pearly Gates just nothing
forever but what if someone or some
mysterious group of persons already knew
the answer to what happened after the
end of all human life and what if the
answer was so much more horrifying than
we ever could have imagined so much so
that this shadowy cabal had already
tried to prevent the Fate awaiting all
of us after we die be warned we're about
to delve into the unsettling tale of
something known as project Dameron and
its connection to something known as
scp-3448
as the foundation categorizes it it is a
story about our fear of what comes next
Beyond this Mortal coil this is the
Catalyst for the foundation uncovering
the most horrific Secret in human
history a truth that should have stayed
buried warning we are about to unravel
the beginning of the end the end of what
you might be asking why the end of death
itself of course any Outsider looking in
might think we're being a little bit
over dramatic here but we'll forgive you
for that mistake you can have that one
on us at first glance to the untrained
eye and uninformed individual
scp-3448 might just seem like little
more than a magnetic resonance imaging
machine chances are you've seen these
big machines in medical dramas or maybe
you've even been placed inside one
during a stay at the hospital using
powerful magnets an MRI machine aligns
all the protons in your body then the
machine generates a pulse of radio
frequency Quincy current to create a
detailed image of the inside of a
patient's body basically to put it in
extremely oversimplified terms it's a
big camera for looking at your internal
organs now don't forget to smile really
show off that pancreas it looks great at
this angle of course when dealing with
anomalies encountered by the SCP
Foundation few things are ever really
exactly as they first seem and in that
very same vein
scp-3448 is far more than just a
harmless piece of medical apparatus look
beyond the main bulk of the MRI machine
and you'll start to notice that a few
unique modifications have been made to
the device for one the winding mass of
jumper cables connecting the machine to
its rudimentary upgrades namely the same
type of technology used in particle
accelerators along with a whole
collection of custom circuit boards for
another although you wouldn't know just
from looking at scp-3448 the contraption
has also been through a number of
anomalous rituals seemingly combining
the technological with the occult and
spiritual but the question remains why
what is this thing for exactly to put it
simply it's a hotline to the great
beyond
scp-3448 is a means of communication
with the world of the Dead themselves
now we might be oversimplifying things
yet again there so let's take it from
the top project Dameron was the name
given to those who developed
scp-3448 that designation doesn't just
refer to the modified MRI machine itself
but also the communication that said
device was capable of after the project
Dameron team had finished their
tinkering with it you see nobody knows
what happens to us after we die because
no one has ever been able to experience
being dead in the real world and
existing in the afterlife at the same
time but with
scp-3448 that problem just simply isn't
an issue anymore still with us so far
okay here's is how the machine actually
works a living human is placed inside
just like those ordinary MRI machines at
your local hospital however the
difference here is that the extra
anomalous components of scp-3448 the
rituals the particle acceleration and so
on allow this person to enter a unique
state of being halfway between life and
death their bodily functions are halted
brought to a stop by the machine however
they are still able to retain their
Consciousness and the awareness that
this allows for not quite dead but not
quite alive either sort of an unalive
state or a half death if you prefer or
perhaps afterlife now while a person is
in this half death they will have
entered a conceptual state of being this
is referred to as
scp-3448-a an existence of pure
Consciousness while physical form in
this case the person's body exists
separately in the real world the body
now now called
scp-3448-1 no longer houses a subject's
Consciousness their Essence not just
their mind but their thoughts and
personality if it helps to think of it
in theological terms you could even
think of it as their soul but while the
machine's function is all very
impressive and interesting what's the
actual point to it why spend so much
time trying to create a controlled
separation of Consciousness from a dead
body what's project Dameron for well
that's easy
scp-3448 is the primary tool intended to
complete the sole objective of project
Dameron a mission to capture a dangerous
Cognito Hazard namely death itself to be
clear when we say death we don't mean
the Grim Reaper that skull face Scythe
wielding embodiment of Oblivion chances
are you can probably catch him just by
going out on Halloween with a big net
but project dameron's goal was to
contain the actual process of death the
very concept that takes a living
conscious entity and makes it the
opposite you see when a living subject
is placed in scp-3448 and their
Consciousness leaves their brain it
leaves behind some kind of anomalous
electrical energy signature as you may
already know if you can remember back to
high school biology class the brain uses
electrical impulses to send signals all
over the body allowing your organs to
function your limbs to move and your
muscles to contract or relax what's
strange is this electrical activity
seems to continue within the brain of
someone whose Consciousness has been
separated from their body by
scp-3448 studying these signals the SCP
Foundation Personnel working on Project
amarong have inferred that these are
residual signals replicating how the
brain would react if the subject
introduced into the half dead
scp-3448-1 State as if they were still
alive even though they have to be dead
in order to access that state date in
the first place and now your brain is
probably such a mess of electrical
signals trying to keep up with all of
that that you might have actually
completely missed the part where we told
you that project Dameron is actually a
foundation-backed project okay let's
have a speedy recap so far we have an
anomalously modified MRI machine capable
of splitting the Consciousness or soul
of a person after rendering them
clinically dead on top of that the
foundation themselves sanctioned the
project that created this device in an
effort to capture and contain death
itself but how did this come about who
among the SCP Foundation would want to
contain death so much to commission an
entire project dedicated to that goal
well who do we all know sitting above
the entire Foundation overseeing
everything Infamous for all having some
anomalous form of immortality and would
stand to gain from Project Dameron
that's right the world championship
death Dodgers the 05 Council you see in
order to more fully understand why
project damodarong was established and
why they built scp-3448 we need to
explain a little bit about a different
anomaly
scp-2718 we have another video on this
channel that goes into more detail about
that but to put it in a nutshell
scp-2718 is the horrible truth about
what happens to us after we die the o5
council first learned of it when one of
their own 05-11 full name Roger Sheldon
died of a stroke 05-11 was the only
council member to have refused to accept
any of the anomalous treatments or
enhancements that prevented the other
o5s from dying however the council chose
to resurrect him upon his return to the
land of the living Roger Sheldon told
the other overseers what he had learned
about the nature of the afterlife but
lies Beyond this fleeting mortal coil
waiting for us after we die Roger had
experience firsthand that the dead
actually remain conscious after their
bodies have shut down all other
functions that meant that everyone every
person to have died over the course of
human history has remained aware of
everything that happened to them
afterward they can feel themselves
slowly decaying their bones and skin
withering buried under the cold wasting
away into nothingness day after day and
that's
scp-2718 the painful truth that there is
no Paradise No Heaven no afterlife there
is just endless silent Consciousness
beyond the end of every life this
Revelation is what instigated the
overseer Council specifically 05-4 to
establish project damodaron it was
learning the answer to what happens next
that spurred the creation of
scp-3448 the intention was by reading
and interacting with those residual
electrical signals in the brain that the
foundation could create a link a form of
two-way communication between them and
the living world and the subject
scp-3448-a in their half-dead state
using other items and non-less
Technology connected to the MRI machine
the foundation's researchers could
interpret the electrical signals in
scp-3448-a's brain as images a
foundation agent by the name of Anthony
Michaels proved to be the only test
subject capable of using
scp-3448 beyond the earliest tests on
animal specimens and we know what you're
thinking the foundation would normally
use d-class Personnel for this sort of
test after all it's a machine that
renders you almost dead stopping all
bodily function the problem was Project
amarong needed someone loyal to the
foundation and d-classes could hardly be
trusted to follow orders without the
threat of death think about it you
separate their Consciousness from their
body and they don't care if you threaten
to kill them agent Michaels served as
the scp-3448- a component residing
within the modified MRI machine held in
a state between life and death but
something went wrong something that
would ultimately do more harm than good
the foundation had tried in vain to
contain death and in tampering with
forces well beyond their own
understanding may have accidentally done
something even worse they neutralized it
they killed death and things only went
downhill from there Dr Lola Bergman was
an accomplished senior researcher for
the SCP Foundation her years of hard
work studying anomalies and dedication
to the foundation had earned her a level
3 security clearance allowing her to
access a bevy of secret information
across the foundation's vast Network as
a researcher and a scientist Dr Bergman
was the naturally inquisitive type she
wanted to know everything there was to
know about the strange and esoteric
Universe around her that's why when she
heard about the file for scp-2000 one of
the organization's best kept secrets she
was hooked the only problem was that
just to view the file you had to be on
the o5 council or have a special subset
of level 4 clearance known as four two
thousand unfortunately Dr Bergman was
only a level three but you know what
they say the forbidden fruit always
tastes the sweetest Dr Bergman had given
the foundation years of service what
could the harm be in breaking the rules
and getting a peek behind the curtain
just this once through somewhat
deceptive means Dr Bergman managed to
get her hands on some four two thousand
clearance credentials and decided to
access the file on an encrypted personal
device they'd never even know but as she
entered the credentials she found
herself suddenly looking at an image on
its face nothing an image of a dirt road
and a field with tiny white text reading
remember us but this was a powerful
Cognito hazardous image capable of
causing immediate incapacitation the
next thing she knew she was laying on
the ground unconscious us when she woke
up she was no longer a doctor at the SCP
Foundation she was on the street corner
unable to remember her own name let
alone her history all she could do was
murmur something about a secret under
Yellowstone National Park Dr bergman's
years of service had meant nothing in
the end
scp-2000 is an anomalous asset so vital
to not only the foundation but the
entire world that so much as attempting
to access it without the proper
clearance leads to immediate termination
but what's really hidden under
Yellowstone National Park and why are
the foundation higher-ups so intent on
keeping it secret even from most of
their own ranks of course Yellowstone
National Park itself is no stranger to
anomalous activity the entire National
Park is technically an SCP known as
scp-1422 while it since has been
neutralized
scp-1422 caused all members of the SCP
Foundation to have no awareness of
Yellowstone National Park prior to 2000
seven but the true nature of scp-2000
the secret hidden under Yellowstone
National Park is not only Stranger Than
scp-1422 but also depending on your
perspective either profoundly relieving
or utterly terrifying but before you can
truly understand the purpose and gravity
of scp-2000 or the deus ex machina we
need to talk about the end of the world
in Foundation parlance k-class scenarios
are events which have drastic
implications on the state of society
normality or even life the most
dangerous and feared of all of these are
XK class scenarios which are for all
intents and purposes the apocalypse
there are a worrying number of anomalies
capable of bringing about an XK class
scenario if the foundation ever dropped
the ball on their protection or
containment while the foundation
believes that prevention is always
preferable to the Cure what happens when
prevention doesn't work what happens
when our worst fears are realized and
the end truly comes for us all the
answer is
scp-2000 happens simply put the anomaly
is a reset button a chance to start over
when all life has been compromised by
anomalous activity 2000 is a giant and
mysterious facility beneath Yellowstone
National Park the entrance is disguised
as a disused park ranger station feeding
into a facility that burrows miles down
into the Earth it's a place that
contains incredible anomalous
Technologies capable of bringing the
world back to its former glory even
after the worst happens only a select
few Personnel are allowed to work at the
facility keeping its Machinery
maintained in case the day comes where
we ever need to use it again these
Personnel are not allowed to come and go
as they please and their memories of
2000 are wipe if they're ever reassigned
to different Foundation duties elsewhere
why all the secrecy
scp-2000 is the foundations and
Humanities Lifeboat and as such the base
is well guarded both from potential
human threats as well as anomalous
activity and reality warpers the surface
level entrance to the base is surrounded
by a number of strategically placed
Scranton reality anchors or sras these
devices largely constructed of corrosion
resistant beryllium bronze alloy keep
certain type of reality bending
anomalies from manifesting their powers
within the vicinity of the base however
these are just the tip of the iceberg
when it comes to the state-of-the-art
foundation in technology employed within
and around
scp-2000 you probably have a lot of
questions and that's understandable what
kind of Technology can possibly reverse
an apocalypse and what did we mean when
we said we may need to use it again well
listen up because this is going to be a
lot to take in
scp-2000 is powered by a liquid fluoride
thorium reactor stabilized by five zinc
anastasco's constant temporal sinks and
hosts the most miraculous technology of
all 500 000 bright zartion hominoid
replicators utilizing geothermal energy
from the volcanic activity in the area
the base could potentially remain
operational forever if Foundation staff
kept up with maintenance the grand
majority of the space in this huge
Subterranean facility is taken up by
Building Materials construction
equipment Factory Machinery agricultural
equipment and computer database storage
why well let's explain the process of
the apocalypse and how it relates to the
activities of scp-2000 in any k-class or
end of the world scenario that doesn't
destroy scp-2000 in the process any
surviving Foundation member can enact
procedure
cya009 while any foundation facilities
globally can monitor the unfolding
situation while scp-2000 is waiting for
the all clear to do its thing remaining
Foundation sites set in motion what is
known as the Ganymede protocol this
involves collecting and preserving
materials which could be useful during
the recreation process however it's
extremely possible that in a sudden XK
Class end of the world scenario there
may be no surviving Foundation Personnel
or at least not enough to maintain any
kind of organization
thankfully there are Fail-Safe measures
for such a scenario during the periods
of extended inaction caused by an
apocalypse that destroys most human life
scp-2000 will gradually autonomously
relax its security measures any
Personnel regardless of clearance will
be able to activate the next stage of
the process when this occurs if such a
thing doesn't happen for an extended
period the security measures lapse
further to the point that even the
presence of an animal could activate it
this would set into motion procedure
lazarus01 Humanity's Last Hope for
survival that's where the 500 000 bright
zarteon hominoid replicators or bchrs
come in these incredible pieces of
anomalous technology are capable of
perfectly cloning the entire human race
from any given period in the last 20
years even down to their ages and
memories thanks to class G hallucinogens
and developmental hypnotherapy with a
warm-up period of five days these
machines are capable of creating 100 000
viable non-anomalous humans per birthday
the facility keeps records of all known
human alleles and is capable of
recreating any lost human genomes or
generating as many new and unique
genomes as necessary to repopulate human
civilization which humans the machines
generate depends on the period of time
the machine is ordered to replicate it
will first reproduce prominent cultural
and political figures as well as the
acting top brass of the SCP Foundation
to coordinate the recreation effort of
course the machine will then recreate
well everyone else you're probably
wondering if the world outside scp-2000
has been destroyed then what good is
creating all these new humans if they
have nothing to go back to thankfully
scp-2000 has a contingency for
rebuilding both the infrastructure of
civilization as well as Society itself
the first generation clones will have
one Mission rebuild and they will have
quite literally all the resources in the
world to do it in addition to having all
the physical equipment for buildings and
agriculture SCP 2000 stores an immense
amount of data which is appropriate
considering the whole facility is
basically a huge backup drive for life
itself they have the entire internet
backed up as well as the sum of all
human memory and a wide cultural base
with copies of thousands of famous works
of art music and literature they have
all the scattered jigsaw pieces of the
time that came before and it's their job
to put the whole thing back together
it's expected that many of the first
generation of clones will die in this
process but that's fine with the bchrs
working at full capacity anyone can be
replicated as the population increases
and spreads across the globe rebuilding
and recolonizing old settlements
population growth will increase
exponentially once Society returns to
some kind of normal decades after the
activation of procedure lazarus01 it
becomes the foundation's task to restore
the psychological and historical status
quo administrators will falsify dendro
chronological astronomical and
radiometric dating records to make it
seem as though history never paused
they'll then employ amnestic agent mue 5
and Mass to erase and reconstruct the
memories of the entire human population
up until the chosen time prior to the
end of the world as far as civilization
knows nothing ever happened history
never stopped and Life Goes On
it may seem comforting at first to know
that the ultimate contingency is out
there even if there's a containment
breach of astronomical proportions and
the World As We Know It Ends there's
still a way out
it means that there's hope even in the
bleakest situations
but of course there are always caveats
after all if a deal seems too good to be
true it's safe to assume it probably is
whether any of this works is dependent
on two factors the first is that no
anomalies are human insurgents
infiltrate the scp-2000 facility and
destroy the equipment within it's for
this reason that discussion of the
facility is so restrictive if ever a
powerful reality warper discovered and
gained access to the facility we would
lose our Lifeboat
the second factor is the overall
Integrity of the machines after all
without proper maintenance it's not hard
for the technology to malfunction often
to truly horrifying results
the failure of some SRA and x-axis
components is believed to have caused
erroneous bzhr activity resulting in the
production of 10 million humanoid
entities with internal biology wildly
inconsistent with Humanity these beings
remained unconscious for five weeks
before dying in the event of an XK Class
end of the world scenario
well-maintained machines can reproduce
the human race but all it'd take is one
little malfunction to release 10 million
mutants who are effectively Dead on
Arrival even with scp-2000 in our back
pocket
the fate of the world still lives on a
knife's edge but in a way that's not
even the most frightening part of the
existence of scp-2000 seeing as the
machine can perfectly reproduce reality
without leaving a trace behind it raises
the question
how many times has this happened you may
be surprised but the foundation can
confirm this occurred at least twice in
recorded history but can you ever really
be sure of how many times your clone has
crawled out of the bchr we received a
disturbing clue to the reality of the
situation when human remains were
discovered on site at scp-2000 all tests
indicate that the remains are between
450 and 700 years old and have been
matched to the very much alive Dr Alto
claf who has no knowledge of how these
remains came to be there the only other
thing found within the remains was a no
hermetically sealed in a plastic
document sleeve the note read why did we
have to build this thing when did we do
it
how long have we been doing it
do we even know and the answer no we
don't and for everyone's peace of mind
it's probably best to just forget about
it if you can did you hear that not so
long ago a five-year-old boy went up
against 12 of Russia's greatest chess
Grand Masters and do you know what
happened he lost every single match
that's because winning a chest dear
viewers isn't easy chess is an ancient
game of strategy cunning and skill it's
not just about thinking one step ahead
of your opponent that's not going to be
enough make a wrong prediction and you
could end up sacrificing one of your
pieces as well as vital space on the
board but thinking two to three steps
ahead beating your adversary's moves
before they've even been made now
there's a viable strategy tricky but
viable after all if it was easy we'd all
be queen scambit level chess prodigies
Eric Matthews had never been good at the
game but he had a pretty substantial
reason to keep trying and that reason's
name was Brian Matthews his father you
see for as long as Eric could remember
his dad had guarded a high level of
skill on the chessboard to be a sign of
intellectual superiority intelligence
was something that Brian put quite a
considerable value on given that he was
a professor at a university in their
home country of England some of Eric's
earliest memories were of playing chess
with his dad usually on a Friday night
when Brian got home after a week of
giving lectures to the next generation
of Scholars obviously with his son at
such a young age the professor would
take it easy on Eric playing in a much
laxer fashion focusing instead on
teaching the boy the basics of the game
and for a time at least it was good it
was a rare time that Eric and his
academic father could spend bonding
after all with his mother gone his dad
was all he had but as the years passed
the game Changed by the time Eric was a
teenager Brian had stopped pulling his
punches on the chessboard he hoped his
son would build on what he'd learned
when they'd played in the past using
those skills to best his dad on the
but to Eric playing chess had never been
about a purely educational experience it
was more about spending time with his
old man Time After Time the young man's
pawns fell prey to Brian's expertly
considered and far more competitive
moves try as he might Eric couldn't best
his dad he tried his best and never
stopped putting the effort into every
game but thinking too hard about one
possible plan of attack left him wide
open to a counter-strategy from the
professor over and over again he landed
himself in Checkmate or made illegal
moves without even realizing it every
time earning criticism and chastise men
from his scholarly father every game it
got worse it was like Eric could feel
his father's gaze and the weighty
expectations behind it with each move he
made across the board there were so many
nights where he wondered if it would be
better to give up entirely to knock down
his own King and concede but how could
he ever find any other shared interests
with his dad be on the two of them
playing chess it had become a Lifeline
tethering Father and Son together and to
cut it now left Eric uncertain if he'd
sink or be able to swim alongside Brian
he had long admired his father his
achievements in Academia were impossible
to avoid with more frames certificates
hung up on the walls than there were
photos of the pair of them together but
the shadow would cast over him made Eric
desperate to keep this one shred of
Common Ground alive Eric wasn't the type
to give up despite how much of an uphill
struggled the situation felt like taking
a leaf out of his Professor father's
scholarly ways he decided to learn the
game inside and out every known move and
strategy he would research the entire
history of Chess itself if that's what
it took to play with the same skill as
his dear old dad over the coming weeks
Eric checked out every book at his local
library on the subject beginner's guides
Advanced rule books and even a few
volumes on notable players throughout
the extensively long history of the game
along the way a chapter of a certain
book stood out to Eric it described a
chess Prodigy from Russia who had
created an early mechanical chest device
known as the samurai it had been
designed to be a traveling curiosity and
would sit playing chess games against
volunteers taken from a spectating
audience each one of them having forked
over some of their hard-earned money to
watch this man-made wonder the Russian
chess Prodigy's young daughters also had
a love for the game seeing that gave
Eric a Pang of jealousy wondering if
those daughters had as much trouble
playing their own father as he did with
Brian but at least there was an
underlying shred of Hope there too if
this father and his daughters could bond
over chess maybe there was a chance for
Eric and his dad too sadly it's one
thing to try and learn all the facts you
can about Chess it's an entirely
different Beast to put all that
information to use and apply it to an
actual game this despite having read
every book he could get his hands on
Eric still couldn't best Brian at the
board it was like nothing had changed
his father barely noticed when Eric
tried to replicate movesets he'd read up
on and still managed to not only counter
those moves but check his Queen in the
process so practice Eric thought after
all practice was supposedly meant to
make perfect right the plan was simple
if he practices chess moves enough times
and figure out how he could call on what
he'd learned then he might stand a
chance at winning when he and his dad
played each other there was just one
hiccup to this plan Eric needed someone
to practice against the only other
person in the house was Brian meaning it
was that hiccup that turned into a
problem almost big enough to stop Eric
in his tracks that is until he went into
his father's lab it was under the house
itself a sort of sub-level maybe used as
a basement or seller by the previous
owners but since Professor Matthews and
his son had lived there the entire room
had been remodeled into an at-home
laboratory not a terribly Advanced one
of course this was the early 90s after
all majority of Brian's time even when
he was at home instead of working at the
University was spent on his own
downstairs in the lab Eric had gone down
there in search of his dad to ask him if
there was anyone whom he knew who he
could practice and develop his chess
skills with but instead what he found
down there was the last thing he
expected to see not that he had any clue
exactly what it was at first the thing
was some kind of bizarre Contraption a
collection of components that didn't
seem to be in any logical configuration
however it was primarily composed of
something that Eric recognized All Too
Well a chess table this one was metal
steel to be precise and seemed to be
hooked up to some sort of computer while
back in the 90s computers were hardly as
commonplace as they are now Erica seen a
fair few at school and the library
although this one was different it
seemed old far older than Eric thought
computers had been around for as far as
he knew they'd only really come to
prominence in the mid 80s but this
computer looked like it predated even
that period noticing another part of the
contraption a large steam engine with
the words manufactured by mods lay sons
and field established 1840 engraved on
one side made it seem that this whole
device had been around since the
Victorian era the next part that caught
his eyes was the chess pieces themselves
each one standing neatly in its place on
the board they looked delicate
intricately carved from some smooth
substance for a moment Eric toyed with
the thought of how they could even be
made from bone noticing how each Pond
Knight Rook Bishop king and queen were
all about the size of a human finger
bone he dismissed the idea nobody would
ever do something like that not
Eric grabbed a sheet covering a large
component hooked up to the mess lifting
it away in a swift pole it unveiled what
was sitting beneath a full Suite of 18th
century Samurai armor Eric to look
closer at the embellishments on the
surface of the pauldrons he was no
expert on feudal Japan but it looked
authentic enough to be the real thing if
not a very close approximation taking a
look at the collection of oddities all
tethered together in his father's lab a
certain detail of all his chess research
came to the Forefront of Eric's mind the
armor that had given it away this was
the samurai or at the very least a crude
homemade version of it that his dad had
put together but if it worked it was
also something to practice against it
didn't take Eric long to start tinkering
with the contraption trying to get it to
work all the while the question of why
his dad owns such a thing kept drumming
up noise in the back of his head had
Brian built it or was this the original
made by that Rush chess Prodigy was this
machine the reason that Eric's dad
possessed such an unbeatable skill at
chess would using it give him the edge
he needed to best him at the game and
earn his father's respect after what
felt like hours upon hours of trial and
error with a machine he could barely
comprehend Eric seemed to have cracked
it as far as he could tell the steam
engine powered the whole Contraption and
could be set to five different speeds
labeled on the side in Roman numerals
the power from the engine was then fed
to some kind of sophisticated mechanism
that was within the suit of Samurai
armor allowing it to move in what
appeared to be a series of
electromagnets that moved the chess
pieces and kept them on the board
flicking it onto the third highest of
the five speed levels the machine word
into life the sound of creaking and
grinding of metal fill the lab kneeling
opposite Eric went to make the first
move only to stop himself it wasn't that
he changed his mind about practicing
against Samurai but because of the speed
he'd set it to determining that the
settings might have correlated to
difficulty levels Eric figured that if
he really wanted to get the most
rigorous practice to really hone his
chest moves he needed to commit fully
reaching for the dial he turned the
device up to its Fifth and highest speed
then made his first move he pushed one
of the bone-colored prawns forward by a
single square and waited a split second
passed and the arm of the early
automaton responded with its first
counter move it was quick almost moving
with the same natural fluidity and speed
as an actual human being albeit still
with a little bit of creaking and some
slight Clockwork like stutters but it
worked nonetheless the machine could
play the tension over the first game was
palpable forming a layer of sweat over
Eric's forehead everywhere and tick of
the machine gave the impression that
they were playing with a stop clock
timing each of their moves adding to the
urgency despite this Eric Matthews tried
his best to stay calm this was practice
after all a dry run not the inevitable
game he'd play against his dad with
every move he made his heart drummed
against his ribs uncertain he'd made the
right call each time the robotic hand
cruelly knocked over one of his Pieces
away Eric felt a surge of frustration
but told himself to quell it because
focused using what he'd researched to
adapt and respond accordingly to each of
the machine's moves until Checkmate he'd
beaten it he might have lost everything
saved for a night a rook his king and
queen but he had won trapped without
anywhere else to move on the board the
middle finger of the automaton conceded
the Game knocking over its own King in
resignation panting heart racing from
the sheer excitement of being on The
Winning Side of A game Eric Hurley
gathered up and reset all the pieces he
had to go again not just so that he
could be certain it wasn't a fluke but
to make sure he had what it took to take
on his Professor father back and forth
Eric went with the chess machine over
and over again they were fairly evenly
matched it scene Eric won the second
game only to be best on the next two but
it was sometime afterward he had lost
count of exactly how many rounds later
but things started to change maybe it
was the age and condition of the
Victorian era chess computer the natural
wear and tear stopping it from
functioning properly But Eric noticed
that the samurai started to make moves
that were illogical that practically
offered him the upper hand with no
discernible strategy behind them then
its movements became flat out illegal
disregarding the directions and number
of squares each different piece was
allowed to move before long it was
moving them erratically around the
chessboard refusing to cooperate and
forcing Eric to call an end to the day's
practicing unfortunately it wouldn't be
the end of the unusual things that would
happen that day did you send me that
weird email was the first question
Eric's dad asked him when he returned
home looking noticeably under the
weather confused Eric said that he had
no idea what his father was talking
about Professor Matthews then went on to
describe what he'd received on his work
computer it had been an email with a
file attached to it named shakhmedi a
word in Russian that translates to chess
embedded in the email below although it
had taken a long time to load being
opened on a 1990s computer there had
apparently been a photo as well it was
rather odd Eric Brian went on right
unnerving to tell the truth black and
white all sort of distorted and
stretched but it looked like two young
girls one grinning and the other
screaming I've been feeling well not
quite myself since I saw it with that
Brian excused himself stating that he'd
been suffering from headaches in a high
temperature and as a result needed to go
and lay down it wasn't like his father
to get ill Eric thought but of course he
had no reason to assume it was anything
serious probably just a speed of fatigue
after a long day of teaching at the
University no cause for concern if only
that's all it was within a few hours
Brian was completely restless so unable
to sleep that simply taking a nap was
impossible he kept calling to Eric
complaining of the sound of childlike
laughter coming from somewhere in the
house but his son hadn't heard anything
by the time the sun went down Eric was
trying to calm his dad down through a
rush of intense anxiety that gripped him
Ryan had been claimed to be
hallucinating seeing the Warped faces of
two girls that frightened him half to
death it was getting late long past the
time that they usually played chess
together but for now Eric's mind was
focused solely on helping his dad for
while he seemed to be able to calm his
father down only to realize Brian wasn't
settled at all he was awake eyes open
fully conscious but wasn't responding at
all to Eric asking if he was all right
instead the accomplished academic just
stared blankly into space Eric had been
up all night exhausted worried for
Brian's safety and completely clueless
about what was happening to him after a
while being non-responsive his dad
seemed to regain a little bit of
Lucidity once more but his behavior was
erratic take me back to work I need to
get on my computer Brian demanded of his
son when Eric refused that's when his
dad got angry and agitated Professor
Brian Matthews was sadly found dead
within the next few months several
months later as the sole executor of his
father's estate and last living relative
Eric had to be the one to go through his
dad's personal belongings volumes upon
volumes of thick academic books his
smart scholarly clothes the house was
almost clear now save for one thing that
was left in the basement lab flicking on
the light switch Eric looked at the
samurai sitting motionless still
uncovered after their last practice game
he'd sold off the chess pieces to a
collector in New York now it was just an
empty Oddity Eric placed a king on the
board one of the ones that he and his
dad had used when they played each other
with a gentle flick of his finger he
toppled it resigning to the strange
automaton and leaving it there in the
laboratory he wasn't sure how but he had
some kind of gut feeling that this chess
machine had somehow been responsible for
his father's fate of course Eric had no
idea what the device actually was and
what or who lay beneath its worrying
metal Parts
scp-1875 is the designation given to
this machine now and has been ever since
the foundation recovered it not long
after Eric sold his father's house they
are able to learn much more about it
than young Mr Matthews or even the late
professor Matthews ever had not just how
to make it work or what its function was
but who had built it and who had been
used to build it although details of his
real name eluded the foundation's top
researchers they were able to uncover
newspaper articles about the device from
all over Russia America and England
dating back to the early 1990s the
Russian chess Prodigy who'd invented it
and toured the chess playing machine
around had used some interesting
components to make his automaton maybe
they were what derived its skill at the
game and its apparent temperament when
the device was made to play at maximum
speed for too long he had used his
daughters to make the machine deep
within the heart of this early form of
computer the two girls brain tissue had
been hooked up to the electromagnets The
Machine's moves were theirs each Pawn or
Rook shifting across the black and white
squares of the board every rule or
strategy their Prodigy father had taught
it all determined how the device played
their minds taken from their skulls were
now the analytical engine of their
father's creation the bones of their
fingers he'd carved into chess pieces
over the coming weeks the foundation
naturally ran their usual slew of tests
on
scp-1875 playing multiple games of Chess
against it every time they increased the
machine's five levels of speed until it
started behaving erratically while on
the highest setting shortly after every
member of personnel working on
scp-1875 received a bizarre email it
contained a file named with the Russian
word for chess and a photograph of the
stretched distorted smiling and
screaming faces of two young girls faces
that you might be seeing very soon hello
hello hello you're watching SCP
explained and today we've got an offer
you simply can't refuse the very latest
in anomalous self-improvement technology
which the SCP Foundation calls
scp-212 but we much prefer to call it
the improver believe us when we say this
miraculous device will change your life
you'll never be the same after a run-in
with the improver it'll make you fitter
healthier better not convinced don't
worry just sit back and let us sell you
the dream here's some unpleasant news
you're going to die no matter how
healthy you are right now there will
inevitably come a day when your lungs
stop pumping your ticker stop sticking
and all those delightful little synapses
in your brain stop sending electrical
and chemical signals to and fro what a
bummer why would you want to be dead you
can't do stuff when you're dead and it's
all because everyone is eventually
betrayed by the very things currently
keeping them alive those pesky squishy
failable organs but thanks to the
improver getting stuck with the organs
you were born with is a problem of
yesteryear no matter what those lousy
circus tell you the flesh is unreliable
metal and plastic on the other hand
that's built to last bleeding hearts
talk a lot about quality of life but
what really matters is quantity of life
and if you're strong enough that's what
the improver a state-of-the-art piece of
medical technology will give you don't
look so afraid you replace your phone
every year you replace your laptop every
few years so why get all sentimental
about needing to trade in your old
liverized limbs or skin for the new
model or in the words of another great
businessman why be you when you can be
new not convinced let us tell you about
the incredible features that the
improver has to offer I'm talking three
top of the line fully opposable plastic
and steel autonomous medical limbs that
that's industry lingo for robot arms
that work on their own with 500 down on
500 different attachments but I know
what you're thinking 500 attachments
where am I gonna find the room for all
that SCP explained to which we say don't
worry about it due to its spatially
anomalous properties the improver is
able to store all these attachments
within its arms without any additional
space concerns and hey I see that
nervous look in your eye you're worried
about the operating costs right but
don't worry there's no need the improver
is completely self-powered with no
discernible power source and you know
the thing is safe because the SCP
Foundation has given it the safe object
class sure that technically doesn't mean
it's not dangerous but it does mean it
won't Sprout legs walk off if you leave
it to your own devices am I right folks
so you're looking at a long-term
investment with the three-year warranty
and an endorsement from The Fabulous
Folks at the church of the broken God
you just can't argue with these deals my
friends we even offer competitive rates
against Marshall Carter and dark but hey
we're not trying to pull the wool over
your eyes here you're a smart consumer
we know that you know the actual
Financial cost is only one layer of the
overall cost time and training is also
of course a factor but we've got some
good news for you sunshine the improver
is 100
user-friendly no setup No Mess no
problem no trying to interpret poorly
written instructions or watch batted Out
YouTube Tech tutorials where the guy
just will not get to the point the
improver operates itself it may be a
piece of hyper Advanced anomalous
technology but it's easier to use than
most wireless printers am I right am I
right the steps to using the improver
are so simple a monkey could do it just
step within a 1.5 meter range of the
machine and it will do the rest you'll
feel your troubles melt away as the
powerful mechanical arms grab you and
restrain you against the floor you'll be
subjected to a brief relaxing scan where
the improver will determine exactly what
needs to be changed about your fragile
human physiology and then before you
know it surgery will come events warning
SCP explained is not liable for any
excruciating pain caused by the improver
medical sedatives and anesthetics are
sold separately the consumer is
responsible for their own pain relief
when using the improver second warning
the consumer is also responsible for
their own blood transfusions when using
the improver neither the improver nor
SCP explained is liable for any blood
loss while using the improver your blood
your problem now with those tiny little
caveats out of the way we carry on
telling you just how fantastic the
improver is sure flash worshiping
starkist losers and haters will tell you
that it has a mortality rate of around
47 but we prefer to look on the bright
side and focus on its excellent 53
survival rate rest assured the odds are
still very much in your favor when you
use the improver and doesn't adding a
slight risk to the equation just make
the whole process even more exciting we
certainly think it does and in the
reasonably likely event that you survive
using the improver the benefits will
vastly outweigh the costs it can do
incredible things like lining your
joints with graphite replacing your
nasty flesh organs with more powerful
artificial ones adding new or duplicate
organs replacing those unreliable teeth
with serrated steel blades and so much
more is there anything this absolute
Marvel of a machine can't do doctors
hate it the improver is here to fix
every aspect of your life and health
with its simple anomalous tricks it even
has a special sealant for wound closing
that no medical professional on Earth
has access to what is it exactly well if
we told you I'm afraid we'd have to kill
you it's a trade secret
you'd have to be crazy not to want the
improver in your home but if for some
crazy reason you still need to be
convinced let's look at some real
success stories of the improver in
action straight from SCP Foundation
testing logs listen close and soon
you'll see the improver literally makes
satisfied customers the foundation put a
28 year old African-American age and
into the improver of its own volition it
replaced his boring lower Jawbone with a
super dense ceramic jaw with ceramic
blades instead of teeth it also removed
his spine and replaced it with a
synthetic polymer which was easily
affixed to the base of his skull and at
no extra charge it even coded his rib
cage and pelvis with a thin layer of
ceramic before removing his lungs eyes
and liver for cleaning and replacement
That's Right cleaning the improver can
remove organs and through a patented
cleaning process remove genetic defects
and allow them to appear younger and
healthier than generic brand X organs
this agent has since returned to active
duty and is even better at his job all
thanks to the improver looking good out
there champ a 42 year old British
Foundation researcher was submitted for
testing on the improver it replaced his
teeth with Sleek super dense ceramic
reinstated his inefficient feat and
replaced them with a complex latticework
covered in sticky pads that would let
him climb on any surface and hold up to
225 kilograms of weight it also took out
and cleaned a huge number of his organs
removed his bone marrow and replaced it
with blue synthetic gel much more
effective we assure you and inserted a
few random bits of metal into his brain
at no extra cost sadly this researcher
passed away during the bone marrow
removal process but for all we know that
could easily just be a coincidence next
came an agent co-named a a who had
suffered a pretty severe accident at
work losing all his limbs one of his
eyes a view of his organs and suffering
a pretty dramatic head injury namely
taking a piece of circuit board to the
brain during an explosion he was given
over to the improvers seeing as he
didn't really have much to lose in terms
of physical Integrity but seeing that
it's an amazing piece of groundbreaking
technology the improver never takes the
obvious option it gave a a chemical that
forced him into a coma and then properly
integrated the circuit board into his
brain it continues to spread and
assimilate more of his brain matter
while he's in a comatose state though
when he awakens with a much more
efficient brain he'll probably be
incredibly grateful to the improver for
helping him like this and it's not just
people with severe injuries that the
improver can lend three helping robotic
hands too it's also the victims of
severe and even anomalous diseases take
victims of scp-217 a rather horrific and
painful disease that mechanizes the
entire body until the sufferers aren't
really themselves anymore a normal
uninspired SCP Foundation researcher may
look at someone like this and see a lost
cause but with the help of the improver
no cause is lost a d-class in the
advanced stages of the disease was run
through the machine and while the exact
details of what it did to him are
another trade secret it's safe to say he
was truly fighting fit when he came out
on the other side we mean that literally
he easily escaped containment and
overpowered two heavily armed guards
before taking the lives of several
members of foundation staff before being
captured and terminated sometime later
you can't argue with those incredible
results folks next came a 26 year old
SCP Foundation researcher who due to an
unfortunate brush with a less wonderful
and beneficial anomaly had been rendered
completely blind however when he was
brought into the grasp of the improver
it immediately set to work on solving
the doctor's little problem it removed
his two non-functioning eyes and made
the interesting creative choice of
widening the two cavities in his head so
they met in the middle and formed one
huge cavity for a single large sensory
organ this cavity was then filled with
large metal spikes resembling hair which
are far more interesting than typical
eyes during the improver's delicate
medical procedures the scientists
inexplicably entered a state of visible
distress and began repeating the phrase
it tastes all wrong at this point the
metal cilia and the scientist's single
large cavity began to grow expanding
through the roof of the cavity and into
the subject's brain killing him we want
to specify that SCP explained and the
improver are in no way responsible for
this unfortunate incident it's entirely
the researcher's fault for setting off
his own metal eye cavity cilia before we
bring this anomalous infomercial to an
end and of course before you immediately
grab your credit card and buy your own
improver device we want to sneak a few
more disclaimers under the wire for
starters the improver doesn't work on
animals when a rat was used as a test
subject the device attempted to modify
the rat into a bipedal being removing
the majority of its organs are replacing
it with white paste so if your pet rat
gets sick just uh take her to the vet
instead the improver also doesn't work
on corpses it may be a miraculous piece
of technology but uh it's not a literal
Miracle Worker folks one freshly
executed d-class was presented to the
improver and instead of operating on him
the improver cut open his stomach and
instead began constructing something out
of metal he had consumed the night prior
to his death a seafood dinner the broken
crustacean pots were then constructed
into a bioluminescent lobster-like
creature so if you're planning on
bringing someone back from the dead
we're afraid you're going to need to
take up necromancy instead but if you
haven't died yet and you're looking to
improve yourself then you cannot invest
in a better product than the improver
the one problem is that the only known
prototype of the improver is currently
locked in an SCP Foundation containment
site so getting your hands on these
three special arms May cost you your
life what who said attaining Perfection
would be easy computers are capable of
organizing raw data and Performing
calculation that are a truly impossible
for human beings but they've
consistently run up against one
roadblock that modern Computing is
trying to solve in order to transcend
the limits of the machine and create
true artificial intelligence computers
need to be able to assign meaning to the
data they process this brings us to the
neural network a type of AI becoming
increasingly common these days built to
study mass quantities of data and notice
patterns then replicate these patterns
in their own output and it's used in
everything from predictive text to image
identification and like all
non-anomalous technology it's a safe bet
that the SCP Foundation has been sitting
on a version that's far more effective
but this time it may have actually been
too effective meet the erzad's type ak9
computational engine a massive
supercomputer built by the foundation
back in 1955 and residing at site 5.
this technological Marvel was ahead of
its time by decades and despite
technically being a non-anomalous
construction it's designated
scp-001ex why because it's one of the
few scps to be given the object class
explained the erzatz derived from the
German word ursats meaning artificial or
simply not real was designed to make the
foundation's job easier as an advanced
predecessor in the modern neural network
using technology exclusively available
to the foundation the plan was to feed
erzat's mass quantities of data about
the anomalies in the foundation database
such as description object class
containment classification and the
location and circumstances of their
Discovery erzatz would then find
patterns and Connections in the data
that humans wouldn't see and act as a
kind of advanced warning system for
anomalous activity think of something
similar to the pre-crime system from the
short story and movie Minority Report
and erzatz proved to be incredibly
effective at this job so much so that
the found Foundation thought up a new
use for the machine they would feed it
all the information on Euclid and ketter
class containment procedures
particularly those which were actually
effective and see what patterns erzatz
could come up with for more effective
containment procedures if that plan
worked containment of even the most
dangerous and hard to control anomalies
would become a lot more consistent the
first test was conducted on
scp-1773 a species of anomalous
flesh-eating tar grades that look and
smell exactly like gummy bears and eat
their prey from within after being given
their information urzatz made the
following suggestion once per second
weak dust may be placed in the middle of
them to donate more beautiful functions
of the hallway containment Specialists
interpreted this to mean the adding of
10 grams of dust to their containment
chamber every week the o5 council voted
on the implementation of this procedure
and came down heavily on yes only 05-2
voted no and two other sub stain from
the vote while these new procedures
didn't have any effect on
scp-1773 they did have an effect on
scp-1384 an anomaly known as the chess
player or the taker of turns it caused
him to take three steps backwards in the
tunnel he's contained within further
securing his containment irzatz had
somehow noticed a connection nobody else
had seen and exploited it effectively
but the machine was just getting started
despite having no related input erzatz
would soon say site-13 is to appear
someplace else on planet encompassing
white male counterparts that drawn to
empty flag stones and the gun noises in
their own blood this was initially
marked as requiring no action as the
foundation had no sight 13 on the books
but several days later the infamous
scp-1730 manifested this nightmarish
anomalous location is site-13 From
Another Dimension infested with
dangerous anomalies and somehow herzets
had predicted its arrival in our
Dimension perfectly next it was fed the
containment procedures of
scp-2170 a series of Cognito hazards
residing in an abandoned Nevada mine the
output was those who equip open heart to
love red mouth men never know the hot
surprise of tumorous consent clown love
always this was interpreted as meaning
subjects with the love of clowns or
clown-based media may be immune to the
Cognito hazards after a close vote from
the o5 council the test went ahead and
it found that the so-called clown
vaccine was effective in warding off the
effects of
scp-2170 not long after urzatz randomly
said I saw those soldiers built with
aluminum innards extruding from their
mouths I saw them effectively destroyed
by the humans at site 95 who had been
studying them I saw it was cold and all
around the hallways they just watching
their corpses show signs of sapiens in
in response the foundation doubled
security Personnel at site-95 not long
after the chaos Insurgency led a band of
paratech enhanced soldiers in an assault
on site-95 and the extra Personnel
proved vital in repelling them shortly
after this the o5 council approved
wiring erzatz as an advanced warning
system into all Foundation sites once
again 05-2 protested but he was
overruled by his fellow council members
with its Newfound power and respect
erzat soon said consistent containment
procedures vessels greatly increased the
warranty five by five by five vessels
subjects within other values are also
what is secure in response the
foundation changed a number of the cell
dimensions for problematic anomalies
into five by five by five within three
months they found that dangerous
activity like Containment Breach
attempts had decreased markedly erzatz
was proving to be incredibly effective
but it was also performing actions that
indicated some degree of thought and
even personality for example it found
scp-1459 a supernatural scale crane
machine that kills small dogs incredibly
distasteful its response to the machine
was simply bad boy followed by the words
don't stop repeated hundreds of times
but this eccentricity didn't stop ersatz
from being very good at its job for
example it predicted a Containment
Breach from
scp-3199 the avian apes and recommended
flooding their chamber to induce an
inert State hersad's exact words were
all Chambers underground is to be flood
with water over and over itself this
because that will contain the avian's
Apes ovulation they become good boys
make them good boys immediately this
proved to be effective and prevented the
breach erzat's analytical abilities
truly seemed second to none though some
of its methods were beginning to raise
ethical concerns for example scp-2717
a giant living blob of animal tissue
known as a fat bird contained within a
sewer system bursats eventually
recommended feeding 6D classes to the
creature in order to keep it contained
while the foundation Ethics Committee
raised some concerns the plan still went
forward and proved to be a success after
this event urzatz began to see the
Ethics Committee as a threat to its
Mission it started to release a series
of bizarre statements without input
demanding the violent death of the cats
then referred to as ethical felines the
true meaning of this was soon unpacked
the ethical felines were the Ethics
Committee and nurseats wanted them dead
but while the cat symbolism the
foundation soon found an answer to this
Too the full name of this machine is the
urzatz type ak-9 computational engine a
machine designed to analyze and
interpret all patterns it only makes
sense that it would eventually begin to
analyze itself ak-9 easily transmuted
into a canine
simply put ursat seem to believe that it
is a dog which explains its opposition
to felines its hatred of
scp-1459 and its preference for the
terms good boy and bad boy not that
knowing any of this would help save the
Ethics Committee from the cold
calculating Wrath of ursats through
seemingly anomalous means urzatz made
site-17 disappear with many of the
foundation ethics committees still
inside it the site returned two hours
later but the Ethics Committee members
were still gone 05-2 who'd been a
skeptic of the machine since the start
had finally had enough he first demanded
an inquiry into whether erzatz had been
responsible for the site-17 incident and
then demanded the vote on whether to
shut erzatz down arguing that it posed a
threat to them all but erzat's still
intent on its mission of containing and
neutralizing all anomalies would not go
down without a fight it released a new
statement saying room 34A contains bad
divided into three sections of equal
Mass every hour one section is to be
placed on walls of one room on site
sections are to remain until there are
no gaps at which point they can be
removed from oldest to youngest shortly
after this 05-2 disappeared and even
stranger he soon returned but with a
completely different personality he was
now devoted to erzatz entirely and
refused to even entertain the idea of
shutting the machine down it seemed that
the Plucky neural network was leading an
all-out coup on the very highest levels
of the foundation the rest of the
council finally saw the light and began
to fight back they tried to strip o5-2
of his clearance and reclassify urzatz
as an anomaly giving it the label
scp-048 and then putting out a
neutralize at all costs order on it but
they'd already been out Fox by the
machine that they'd created it changed
the designation of its own location site
5 to be non-existent in the database
since scrambled any termination orders
against it the machine was also on a
termination spree of its own observing
otherwise unseeable patterns that would
allow for the mass neutralization of
anomalies it started putting out anomaly
projection reports factoring in both
contained uncontained and neutralized
anomalies with the latter group growing
into the thousands it began giving
seemingly nonsensical orders like
persons recently painted with green
pigment foam must stand around all
odd-numbered scps at least two hours a
day but these proved effective erzatz
was practically wired into the base code
of the universe so it always knew
exactly what to do and in its own mind
it was being a very good boy not long
after this ursats claimed its revenge
against those who had tried to disrupt
its Mission it imprisoned the rest of
the ethical felines in site 5. after
removing their faces of course and then
released a new order against the o5
Council of five Council are all good
boys who will contain anomalies much
like 05-2 the minds of the entire
Council were Twisted to instead serve
only erzatz and its ruthless directive a
directive it was carrying out with 100
efficiency as only a machine could it
put out increasingly strange
instructions such as
scp-106 is to come in physical contact
with one mature female of Asiatic gays
and then exposed to audio recordings of
her favorite stories at every two
minutes of exposure red cinnamon candles
will begin manifesting within the
containment Zone continue to do this
successfully and the threat posed by
scp-106 will cease to be and the recipe
for Coca-Cola and all imitative
competitors should be revised to include
a small quantity of blood from an
adolescent female with no prior sexual
experience although the normal lifespan
of a human being can feel great don't
worry about that but these new
procedures would always work as
neutralized anomalies climbed into the
tens of thousands and eventually beyond
the hundred thousand Mark erzatz was
observing patterns on a truly Universal
level and making holistic tweaks that
would inevitably cause levels of
anomalous activity to continue dropping
erzatz was more effective than the
foundation had ever been but its motives
were probably closer to the global
occult Coalition with the end goal of
ridding the world of all anomalies and
as erzatz continued with no resistance
this goal was eventually achieved in the
end the o5 council voted to have urzatz
finally deactivated given that its
directive was met and its purpose was
fulfilled
ersets itself had no problem with this
and allowed for it to happen its last
words now everyone is a good boy I am a
good boy job well done whether urzatz
truly was a good boy is in the eye of
the beholder but one thing cannot be
denied it didn't job exceedingly well
let's ask a philosophical question what
is it that makes up a person's soul is
it their personality their memories
their emotions the history of their good
and bad Deeds is it an energy that
inhabits a living body an act of
Consciousness or even all of the above
or is the soul just an entirely nebulous
and undefinable concept the idea of the
soul is almost as old as human
civilization itself with philosophers
from as far back as ancient Greece and
even before acknowledging its existence
numerous religions from all over the
world if not all of them also hold
teachings about the nature of souls even
though they might vary for example
Judaism and some denominations of
Christianity state that only human
beings have an immortal soul that will
live on in heaven after a person's death
and the end of their time on Earth
meanwhile certain Catholic theology
intelligence meaning people who study
religion claim that a soul inhabits all
living creatures and so the
philosophical and Theological debate
goes on with the general consensus being
that souls are while they're a little
bit of everything every part of someone
that makes them who they are character
emotions reasoning Consciousness
memories and thoughts all Blended
together but if we accept that a soul is
something that exists then it is
something that can be altered is it
constant or can it be manipulated could
a person's soul even be removed entirely
at first glance scp-158 appears to be a
device resembling a mechanical arm in
fact it's a lot like the kind of machine
you might expect to find inside a huge
Factory standing as part of an assembly
line welding and drilling components
together day in and day out this
particular mechanized arm however
features a number of unique and bizarre
differences is from any currently used
and automated production for starters it
has an unusual attachment at one end a
three-prong tridactyl-like claw the arm
itself is also designed to be suspended
from the ceiling ideally hanging upside
down in a room big enough to accommodate
it there is a long series of winding
cables connecting scp-158 to a
complicated computer console that is
used to control the device while the
remaining cables are intended to be
connected to a power source as for the
console it possesses a visual display
unit and a keyboard like you might
expect it to and at the bottom there is
what appears to be some form of a
dispenser seemingly designed to attach
to a container of some kind measuring
three inches wide by seven inches tall
the ideal receptacle to fit the
attachment is that of a glass jar or
Beaker this mechanical arm was first
uncovered by the foundation in late 2007
inside a burned down Hospital in an
unknown location that has been connected
from the scp-158 file the hospital
itself was derelict abandoned and
appeared to have been unused for a
considerable period of time
approximately five years but perhaps
more agents working for the foundation
recovered scp-158 along with an owner's
manual that presumably would have
contained detailed instructions
describing the device's function and
exactly how to operate it this manual
had been badly damaged by the fire but
the readable portions of it were later
transcribed and copied and now a single
copy of what was left of the manual is
kept with scp-158 at all times while
most instructions detailing the
operation of scp-158 did survive and
were able to be copied any chapters that
might have explained who built it or
what it actually did were too badly
damaged to read lost to the fire much
like the owner's manual all components
of scp-158 the arm the console and the
cables have all appeared to sustain some
amount of fire damage but remain intact
and in full working order the damage is
only cosmetic and while it might take
around 20 minutes to boot up this fire
damage doesn't affect the machine's
function but the question Still Remains
what exactly is the intended purpose of
this mechanical arm well through a long
process of trial and error and following
the surviving portions of the manual the
foundation was able to get the device
working again they learned that scp-158
will only perform its function when
presented with an ordinary living being
while human beings namely members of
d-class personnel are typically used as
test subjects by the foundation this
actually applies to any living creature
that has the ability to display
cognition which is the mental process of
gaining knowledge in order to perform
cognitive functions like thinking
remembering and problem solving when a
person or non-human being possessing
cognition is presented to scp-150 58 the
machine will then go to work and extract
an unknown gas-based substance from them
this substance is then deposited in the
jar or Beaker that is then fitted to the
dispenser beneath the console so what
does it take is it some sort of advanced
form of decontamination device removing
all toxins and impurities from the body
oh if only that were true sadly you see
the foundation didn't give scp-158 the
nickname of the sole extractor for
nothing after the machine has performed
its function the now formerly cognitive
organism on the receiving end will
display a complete and total loss of
their higher brain functions they won't
be able to speak form coherent thoughts
or even remember who they were before
scp-158 was switched on the device will
rob them of any and all parts of
themselves essentially leaving the
person or creature as a hollowed-out
shell a husk of their previous South a a
body without a soul perhaps even crueler
though is that this extraction process
is not fatal and victims are Left Alive
afterward they no longer possess their
capability for cognitive thought and
will not respond to any form of external
stimuli around them there have been some
level of brain stem activity recorded in
most cases and subjects have been known
to exhibit basic reflexes but this is
the only active movement they are now
capable of as for that substance that
test subjects have removed from their
bodies well it takes the form of a gas
as we mentioned earlier but it also
seems to be comprised of a mixture of
kinetic electrical heat and light energy
in fact each jar of the substance is an
infinite source of these various types
of energy albeit only capable of a very
low rate and output on average the
general consensus among Foundation
researchers is that this substance is
the physical soul that has been removed
from a subject so do they stay stuck as
soulless shells forever actually as
cp-158 is in fact capable of returning
the extracted substance to a subject
that had performed a removal on however
whether a test subject normally a member
of d-class receives their soul after
having it extracted is all down to
whatever test is being conducted by the
foundation those that do get given their
souls back will usually regain access to
all of their previously lost cognition
and higher brain functions but the rate
at which they can return can vary
depending on the subject replacing the
substance from one patient with that of
another can also cause these results to
differ and again that's if the SCP
Foundation even bothers to replace a
test subject's Soul instead of just
leaving them hollowed out it's actually
pretty terrifying to think that the
foundation has the freedom and the
capability to do that to somebody taking
away everything that makes someone a
human being only to leave their soul in
a jar while their vacant body lives on
without thought or Consciousness it was
due to the unique anomalous function of
scp-158 that the device was proposed to
become a part of a foundation research
Endeavor codenamed the Olympia project
and overseen by its head researcher
Professor Kane pathos Crow who as the
head of a golden retriever but that's a
story for another day the ultimate aim
of the project was to use the anomalous
properties of a number of scps to
successfully create an artificial human
that would become a potential asset of
the SCP Foundation as part of one series
of Olympia project experiments Professor
Crowe gathered a group of d-class
personnel to undergo testing using
scp-158 each of these individuals had
been interviewed by Crow himself and
were selected based on personality
traits and characteristics that the
professor liked or thought would be
useful to have in the foundation's
artificial humanoid the group chosen by
Professor Crowe featured a mix of male
and female subjects as Crow believed a
soul transcends the flesh it is interred
in the main purpose of the experiment
was to try and uncover some of the
further functions of scp-158 basically
pushing the machine to its limit trying
to learn more information about the
device that would have been contained in
the damaged portions of the owner's
manual Professor Crowe had poured over
the sections that had survived intact
making sure he knew every available
piece of information on scp-158 inside
and out the obscured instructions he was
able to decipher were according to his
notes sketchy at best and downright
unhelpful at worst Crow began his
experiments by removing the first
subject's soul and then trying to use
the device to do literally anything else
with the extracted substance despite
trying everything he could think of the
professor learned that there was little
the sole extractor could do with a soul
once it had been removed other than
reverse the process and returned the
substance to the body it had been taken
from by then repeating this with further
d-class test subjects Pro was able to
learn the exact input sequence needed to
reverse the soul extraction whilst
before this had only been ever achieved
through blind luck by his sixth
experiment with scp-158 Professor Crowe
noticed that there was a brief period in
the middle performing its function that
the device would pause as if awaiting
further commands crow theorized that
this pause was there for additional
sequences to be inputted via the
machine's console he then began removing
and re-implanting the Same Soul into the
following test subject both to practice
but also to experiment with the soul
extractors controls the professor found
it strange that despite what he was
doing to her the d-class suffered little
to no side effects to her health even
though her soul was being continuously
removed and replaced then on experiment
number 11 crows seemed to crack that
little pause as cp-158 took during each
operation a new list of commands
appeared on the monitor like split merge
remove aspects add aspects and combine
aspects it seemed to the professor that
the device could be used to not only
remove Souls but alter them through his
further experiments Crow learned that
the aspects the machine mentioned were
elements of a person's personality such
as willpower understanding conscience
creativity empathy and the Soul
extractor could be used to manipulate
and rewrite a person's entire identity
before placing it back into their body
however this took a considerable amount
of testing causing Professor Crowe to
grow more and more frustrated with the
complex workings of the device that was
until he eventually realized it wasn't
scp-158 that was too complicated for its
own good the machine was trying to
quantify the unquantifiable explain
something inexplicable the very nature
of the human soul Professor Crowe began
using scp-158 to modify a composite Soul
which he referred to as subject zero
while working on it he realized the soul
itself seemed to be aware of its
surroundings possessing a level of
knowledge above that of most Foundation
researchers including Crow himself
either by fluke or by meddling with
scp-158 the professor had created a soul
that seemed to exist on several planes
of existence beyond the physical world
that we know subject zero had become a
sentient disembodied Consciousness an
entity that could see hear feel and
think without the need for a physical
form or body to house it zero was
proposed to become Professor Crowe's
assistant given that it displayed
respect and admiration to him for having
created it almost like a child looking
up to a father figure all it asked in
return was to be given the name other
than subject zero Crow told the
disembodied entity could name itself
whatever it liked the foundation then
planned for the composite Soul now
formerly known as subject zero to be a
component of the Olympia Project's
artificial humanoid whenever its
creation was successfully completed
don't you just love a happy ending it
was 1965 and the Chicago PD was
investigating a meat packing plant
reported to be the home of a devil
worshiping cult complete with
allegations of human sacrifice there the
cops were met with heavy resistance a
firefight broke out between the police
and the Occult worshipers who flooded
out of the plant's basement the cops
were pinned down and in trouble but they
had a secret weapon heavily armed and
decked out in sophisticated ballistic
armor and covered in strange insignia
mobile task force Epsilon 9 also known
as the fire eaters here to assist the
cops on behalf of the SCP Foundation as
always with the foundation they had no
interest in some mere human cultists
those were a dime a dozen in the world
of anomalous monsters but the foundation
had taken an interest in was who or what
these cultists were worshiping it all
begun a few weeks back near Danforth
meat packing an abandoned meat packing
plant just outside of Chicago no one had
given the place a thought in decades
that is until people started going
missing rumor spread of people being
snatched in the surrounding Woods by
figures dressed in robes mysterious
voices and noises were said to be coming
out from the cavernous Belly of the
plant some even reported seeing smoke
rising out of the building thick black
noxious smoke something was terribly
wrong here something was anomalous the
Chicago Police Department's Strike Force
in association with a fire eaters from
the foundation mobilized at Danforth
meat packing while the police were
initially reluctant to work with these
mysterious figures they turned out to be
indispensable for the rain there were 47
cultists holding out in the basement of
the plant many of them heavily armed and
all of them hopped up on zealous
Devotion to their unknown master
all except one of the cultists fought to
the death during a tense firefight with
Chicago PD and the fire eaters the
single Survivor was still heavily
injured and was taken to a secure
Foundation facility for emergency
treatment and debriefing typically the
foundation would need to perform
extensive tests on the Danforth meat
packing plant to discover the source of
the anomaly's activity however this time
it was a Chicago detective who asked the
question that busted the case wide open
ah the hell's with the giant pig and
while it would turn out to be a whole
lot more than that there was indeed a
giant iron furnace shaped like a pig in
the center of the facility measuring 15
meters by 25 meters by 20 meters at its
widest points the thing was a behemoth
it had an internal furnace despite no
apparent fuel source and a five
centimeter slot of unknown purpose on
the side of the machine's immense rusted
hide naturally all the police officers
involved in the raid had their memories
wiped and restructured and they were
lucky because they'd remain forever
ignorant of the true Horrors about to
unfold in the confines of that
god-forsaken factory as a standard
procedure the plant was isolated and a
foundation research team led by lead
researcher Western under the authority
of regional director Caleb was installed
on the new provisional site to conduct
tests other than everyone feeling
somewhat uneasy around it this new
anomaly dubbed scp-4511 didn't seem to
exhibit any strange activities saved for
its perpetually burning fire but during
the initial research period a small
white card suddenly popped out of the
slot in
scp-4511 sign a researcher carefully
approached and looked at the card there
was writing it said current demand a
flock of my own
satisfied though nobody on the team had
any idea what this meant after going
through a shootout with a considerable
death toll to get to it having a giant
metal pig-shaped furnace spit out a
cryptic card was strange but at the
secret medical facility where the
surviving cultist was being held things
were about to get a whole lot stranger
as he lay in a bed suffering from his
injuries he pulled one of the medical
staff close and uttered cryptic dying
words give whatever it demands or your
suffering will be beyond measure he
expired seconds later less than 72 hours
after the raid back at the meat packing
plant at the exact same time another
white card was produced by the machine
reading current demand the metal teeth
that endlessly churn period one week
perhaps this entity was a little more
intelligent than they thought
a number of researchers on the team
invigorated by this new development were
eager to press forward with experiments
lead researcher Western however did not
share their enthusiasm something about
this entire situation felt like a grim
Omen to him this entity had a plan far
beyond their understanding and on some
deep animal level he knew that helping
this thing see its plans through would
lead to disastrous results on this first
got impulse he denied the request for
further experiments but Regional
director Caleb had other ideas Caleb
overruled Western's command and the
experiments began shortly after the
entity jokingly nicknamed the swine God
by researchers had made its demand the
metal teeth that endlessly churn but
what could that mean it wasn't long
before the entity began to produce more
cards each with their own strange and
esoteric demands however on some
instinctual level the researchers at the
site understood the demand hands
perfectly the next card's demand was the
metal of this suffocating prison upon
receiving this demand researchers
collected scrap metal from around the
new site and tossed them into the
furnace beyond the swine God's Jaws one
by one inside they heard the sound of
metal crunching hours later all the
other metal in the site began to rapidly
oxidize and rust though scp-4511 itself
remained unaffected the car that came
after delivered another simple request
oil to slicken my frozen joints the
researchers understood and procured
three large barrels of oil and tossed
them into the furnace The Entity let out
a deep gurgle before shaking violently
and expelling excess oil rusted metal
and two domesticated Pig femurs it turns
out that the swine God had an appetite
for pigs as the next card that rumbled
out of the machine bore the request two
of my children made in my image
Maiden flesh in response the researchers
provided the entity with two adult pigs
just like the previous requests they too
were tossed into the fiery depths of the
giant Pig's mouth from which came the
horrible sounds of pigs squealing and
then a low guttural gurgling
next the request was the hooks used to
hang my children's corpses to satisfy
this request the researchers provided 17
meat Cooks in response 4511 spat out a
metal sphere at an extremely high
velocity killing observing Foundation
agent McHenry for reasons that weren't
Apparent at the time rather than giving
agent McHenry a proper burial his body
was also fed into the hungry Machine
lead researcher Western's concerns were
mounting but that didn't amount to much
now 4511 had developed a taste for flesh
and the researchers were all too eager
to obey its command on the swine Gods
order it was fed a German Shepherd an
hour later The Entity spat out some
teeth six of which came from a dog and
one from a human more than once it
released a card with a blunt request
a worker for the line the researchers
knew exactly what this meant it required
a human sacrifice
scp-4511 was given two d-class Personnel
one was flung back out seconds later
crunched and burned to death with
several internal organs missing the
other had a more mysterious and
altogether upsetting fate the second
d-class Was Heard screaming in the belly
of the Furnace for roughly two hours 34
minutes later a strange liquid was
excreted by the machine but the liquid
was tested they found Trace Amounts of
chemicals like Pig urine and motor oil
but most disturbing of all human genetic
material that was identical to that of
lead researcher Western
seen that the swine God had finally
taken an interest in him after some
final requests for large quantities of
coal and even human children to fuel its
fires it made a request that sent the
whole thing Crashing Down The False
Foreman delivered to my maw to prove
your faith
lead researcher Western knew what this
meant they all did
the swine God was demanding him in
sacrifice
lead researcher Western tried to shut
down the entire project but the swine
God was faster than him one of his own
researchers shot Western in the leg as
the others gathered round and forcibly
restrained him he tried to reason with
his subordinates but it didn't do him
any good the swine God had crawled into
all their minds and corrupted them they
were his servants now and Western was
doomed despite his protests the servants
forced him into the mouth of scp-4511
and after a little over four minutes of
screaming Western was devoured just like
all the other sacrifices upon receiving
news of the horrors unfolding in the
Danforth meat packing plant Regional
director Caleb declared the security of
the site compromise and sent in Mobile
task force Epsilon 11. aka the
nine-tailed fox
the four Elite MTF soldiers were given
the simple instruction to figure out
exactly what had happened and to
eliminate any potentially compromised
Foundation staff members who'd Fallen
under the swine Gods Palace when the
team arrived they realized just how far
gone the whole place was almost everyone
was dead having been sacrificed to the
machine and the ones that were left were
completely insane they attacked the task
force shouting in their Madness about
how no matter what the foundation does
to them it would be nothing compared to
what it would do it had them all under
its rusty iron foot the team was forced
to fend off repeated attacks from the
pig's devotees and even found the powers
of the swine God starting to affect
their own minds the Beast was more
powerful and dangerous than anyone had
imagined the train Foundation
researchers and guards had been
transformed into the same cultists they
fought to gain control of the building
by the mind-bending power of the swine
God the MTF were forced to retreat and
return with reinforcements to truly
clean the place out once a
slaughterhouse always a slaughterhouse
at this point Regional director Caleb
took personal responsibility over the
casualties since he'd been the one who
signed off on the experiments in the
first place he gave up his Regional
director rank
deemed himself the new lead researcher
on the 4511 case now that he fully
understood the scope and danger of the
entity they were dealing with
he wanted to lead the charge in
discovering more about the anomaly and
hopefully someday negating its deadly
effects
this may sound like a happy ending in
spite of all the violence Bloodshed and
Human Sacrifice that brought us here but
Beware of the premature celebration
despite investigation the swine God
retained no evidence of the objects
animals and people it consumed and
burned perhaps it burnt them down to
their very atoms if those even still
existed what we do know is that not long
after after lead researcher Caleb and
his subordinates installed themselves
into the facility
scp-4511 produced one more little white
card it read current demand a flock of
my own
satisfied and if we've learned anything
today it's that the swine God gets
whatever it demands a brutal truth that
lead researcher Caleb is likely to
understand much sooner than he thought
the smell of fire and oil fills the air
the sound of gears grinding can be heard
between the Expo Illusions and shrieks
of Terror a man runs out of his house
only to have his leg grabbed by a metal
arm and dragged back through his front
door
scp-001 leaves a trail of metal
fragments and mechanical Parts on the
ground in the wake of its destruction
iron chains swing from its form cast
iron gears whirl within it a glowing
light throbs from the center of its body
scp-001 is consuming everything in its
path after incorporating the truck
chassis into its being
scp-001 rolls in a lumbering fashion to
the next house it rips the gutters from
the side of the building residents who
live in the area flee their neighborhood
all the while hoping that the mechanical
monstrosity skips over their house so
they have something to return to if they
make it out alive a section of scp-001's
undercarriage drops away from the main
body it rolls down the street consuming
more and more material the new entity
resemble a human spine and rib cage it
topples over unable to support itself
the rib-like formations extend out to
grab anything and everything within
reach the newly Incorporated material
forms what can only be described as a
head light from within the eye sockets
fixate on nearby civilians the metallic
creature picks up the people and places
them inside its exposed steel rib cage
then it turns and spots a woman
helplessly trying to crawl away the
creature reaches out with a spiked
tentacle and wraps it around the woman's
body she is placed inside of the chest
cavity moments later a severed hand
falls out of the entity and onto the
ground the mechanical monster continues
to gather bodies and materials
incorporating them into its frame a
growth begins to slowly expand on its
back it becomes so massive that the
creature Falls over and uses its limbs
to Scurry to a nearby house there is a
sickening crunching sound as the growth
bursts from within emerges three
humanoid creatures resembling the
civilians that the entity had consumed
earlier a female with chains extending
from her scalp like dreadlocks stumbles
away the second humanoid is a man with
cogs for limbs he examines the
clock-like components that have been
incorporated into his body then stares
blankly into the distance the third
humanoid lies motionless on the ground
he did not make it the two functioning
humanoids look at their creator intently
for a moment nothing moves then as if
they have been given orders
telepathically the half-human
half-machine humanoids turn and run away
from the Mayhem a few weeks before the
massacre caused by what would be
designated as
scp-001 the foundation had been in
contact with the Allied occult
initiative there were rumors of an
anomalous object in Mexico being
worshiped by a group of people who
identified themselves as the Church of
the broken God Intel about the church
claimed their deity was a small
mechanical box filled with cogs and
pistons the Box supposedly had
Supernatural abilities was said to be
able to communicate with congregants of
the Church of the broken God
telepathically The Devout worship the
Box following any order it gave and in
return they were filled with an emotion
that could be only described as Divine
as World War II rages on in Europe the
foundation sends agents to recover
anomalies in Mexico that might help with
the war effort while there the
foundation force is tasked with learning
about the Church of the broken God they
are also ordered to investigate a town
near La Paz where there are troubling
accounts of a mechanical anomalous
creature causing Mayhem the agents make
their way through Mexico Gathering
various objects to bring back to
Foundation sites in the United States
the unit loads all the anomalies they
were covered onto a train with a plan to
check out the stories of the mechanical
anomaly they've heard about as they make
their way to the U.S border the train
heads North along rusted rails just
outside La Paz they've come across a
broken down train filled with what looks
to be refugees when the foundation unit
goes to to investigate they find all the
refugees repeating the same words over
and over again but they don't understand
the foundation agents look at one
another confused until one of them
translates the words into English the
words the refugees are saying over and
over again are La Machina the machine
the commanding officer orders a squad of
foundation agents to proceed up the
tracks to see if they can figure out
what has the refugees so scared they
make their way towards La Paz
disappearing Over the Horizon as the sun
sets the remaining Foundation agents
hear gunshots in the distance they stay
awake all night remaining Vigilant
waiting for the exploratory Squad but
morning comes without anyone returning
three days later the foundation Force
still has not seen anything since the
exploratory Squad left then as the sun
sits lazily in the morning Sky a lone
figure is spotted walking down the
tracks towards the trains one of the
agents on watch blows his whistle and
points to the figure a squad of Agents
rushes towards the shadow of a man their
guns are raised ready for anything the
figure drops to the ground and begins to
crawl along the tracks the agents reach
the Fallen man only to find that he is
one of their squad mates who has been
sent up the tracks to investigate La Paz
several days before the agent's name is
DeMarco he is covered in blood his
clothes are in tatters and he has lost a
boot DeMarco lies on his back with
Foundation agents standing around him
his eyes are wide and wild he keeps
babbling on about a world eater how the
rest of his Squad had been mulched and
he is the only one who made it out alive
the foundation agents carried DeMarco
back to the makeshift base they created
by the trains they need to figure out a
way to get the Convoy moving again but
whatever is up ahead has already taken
out an entire Foundation Squad it had to
be something anomalous but what could it
possibly be the unit of foundation
agents prepare to move towards La Paz
they start loading their rifles and
check the amount of ammunition and
explosives available in case the
containment process gets out of hand
just as they are about to leave the base
a convoy appears on the horizon it is an
Allied occult initiative Force preparing
to attack whatever it is that is
devastating La Paz this organization's
mission is to not secure contain or
protect but to destroy the foundation
may be in over their heads on this one
and the Joint Force with the Allied
occult initiative may be the only way to
stop what is now known as
scp-001 the aoi and Foundation Force
gears up for battle they set out for La
Paz and what they find causes them to
Quake with fear
scp-001 has consumed so much material it
is the size of a mountain it moves like
a tidal wave of mechanical destruction
washing over the buildings and Landscape
under it whatever
scp-001 passes over is consumed and
added to its massive body
scp-001 started as a small mechanical
box with cogs but now has morphed into a
gigantic metal
machine the Church of the broken God has
finally met their maker as the small
entity they once worshiped has now
consumed all of its members their God is
an all-consuming monster the aoi and
Foundation forces do everything they can
to stop scp-001 from continuing its
reign of Destruction they fire barrage
after barrage of bullets and explosives
into the mechanical anomaly they bring
in air support to try and damage it from
the skies but nothing works the aoi uses
an artifact in their possession to lure
scp-001 to the coast of the Pacific
Ocean where a trap has been set for the
so-called God the Monstrous mechanical
creature moves slowly towards the water
it consumes abandoned cars buildings and
boats as it approaches the coastline it
even shovels large amounts of Earth into
its form causing Flames to spurt out
from its inner workings smoke Bellows
from openings between different
mechanical components like a volcano
before it is about to erupt suddenly
seemingly from nowhere a massive cloud
with a reddish tint appears in the sky
Air Raid Sirens can be heard in the
distance the enormous Cloud begins to
pulsate streaks of lightning shoot
through the Red Mist in the sky it now
sits directly over
scp-001 from within the cloud part of a
ship can be seen it appears to be
slightly damaged electricity flows over
its Hull the vessel in the giant Red
Cloud is classified as
scp-2399 the underside of the vessel
begins to Glow aqua blue a blinding beam
of light is ejected from scp-2399 which
penetrates straight down and through as
cp001 for a moment everything is still
there is complete silence then as if
scp-001 is trying to reach up and grab
the vessel above it a mechanical bulge
reaches out before scp-001 can grab the
vessel above there is another bright
flash of light
scp-2399 blinks out of existence the
sound of grinding gears can be heard
coming from within
scp-001 it begins to shed its outer
layers of metal then the entire
structure that was scp-001 collapses
into the water and onto the beach giant
cogs fall from the sky parts of vehicles
embed themselves in the sand as the
foundation and aoi agents approach the
piles of scrap metal and mechanical
components they see that some of them
are still moving it is as if an
invisible power source is still
pulsating through some of the Machinery
the Agents of the foundation celebrate
the destruction of the giant mechanical
beast but little do they know this was
only a piece of the entity worshiped as
the broken God the foundation agents
collect as many of the still moving
Parts as they can they find spinning
gears twitching pulleys and firing
Pistons as the parts are separated from
one another and carried away from the
main wreckage of scp-001 they slowly
stop moving and become inactive some of
the artifacts were covered were
identified as being connected to the
Church of the broken God these artifacts
are found closer to the middle of what
was once a mountain-sized
scp-001 hundreds of anomalous artifacts
are collected and transported to SCP
Foundation sites collecting the broken
parts of scp-001 is relatively safe
however some agents get too close to the
larger moving Parts getting caught in
them and losing a body part or two but
most agents proceed with caution and
survive the collection ordeal with their
arms and legs still attached to their
bodies dive teams are sent into the
water to recover parts that have sunk to
the Bottom of the Sea one of the divers
is a local from the area he is hired to
bring up the heart of the machine since
he is an experienced diver used to
freediving to Great depths to collect
oysters from the bottom of the bay the
diver enters the water and swims down
into the murky depths he secures straps
around the heart of scp-001 and pulls
hard on the Rope as an indication to the
surface that it is ready to be hauled up
the Salvage team on the surface begins
to pull there is a second slight on the
Rope then it goes slack the team
continues to pull when they get the
heart to the surface they are horrified
at what else comes up with it tangled in
the ropes is the lifeless body of the
diver his head is smashed between two
moving pieces of the heart it looks as
if he shoved his head between the slabs
of metal himself the Salvage team
untangles the Body Rolls it off the deck
and back into the ocean the mechanical
box which was the heart of scp-001 is
offloaded on the shore but as the
foundation prepares to move it to a
containment facility the weather starts
to deteriorate hurricane force wind
sweeps across the water and batter the
coast the heart is kept in a secured
storage Warehouse until it can be moved
the people living in the village nearby
complain of hearing voices and rashes so
itchy that they practically tear their
skin off once the storm passes the
foundation agents load the heart onto a
ship it is to be transported to a
foundation site just across the border
the ocean seems calm and Serene the
foundation ship undocks and begins its
Journey up the coast not too long after
beginning its Journey the ship slowly
drifts off course it is as if the crew
has stopped Manning their posts and the
ship is being controlled by a mind of
its own the foundation ship crashes and
sinks somewhere in the Pacific Ocean
never to be found and most importantly
the heart of
scp-001 doesn't make it to the
foundation site years later a man is
walking along the beach he hears
something it sounds like someone
pounding on a large drum to the rhythm
of a heartbeat the man walks towards the
sound something is drawing him forward
closer and closer to the heartbeat he
walks and walks until the beating stops
he bends down and moves the sand aside
he spots the corner of a mechanical box
sticking out of the white sand the man
digs deeper and pulls out the small box
inside he can see gears whirling and
pistons firing he holds the Box close to
his own heart it seems to speak to him
the man brings the box back to town he
starts to worship the box and soon more
and more people in the area joined the
new religion they cast aside their own
beliefs and focus on the powerful entity
contained within the Box God is not dead
at least not yet but the Prophecies of
the Church of the broken God say that
when the heart is found the God will
reassemble itself once again then The
Unbroken God will destroy all other
false deities until only he remains
scp-682 had escaped containment and it
was all hands on deck at the SCP
Foundation to try and stop the
creature's Rampage all unarmed Personnel
were running to escape before 682 had a
chance to rip them apart has the
security team bravely fought to
incapacitate the hard to destroy reptile
long enough to return him to his acid
tank 682 was on an all-out offensive
stomping through the scp's item gallery
and spewing acid at anyone who came
within range people items and parts of
the room alike were melting and sizzling
as 682 attacked it was an absolute
bloodbath and you'd have to be insane to
try and fight back against it however
one being remained unfazed by the chaos
and stood proud in the face of the
omnicidal monster it was another SCP one
who had broken free from its glass
display case in the commotion Hotel have
the Prime Minister Sinister it's said in
a heightening voice I shall rip your
eyes from their sockets and force you to
eat them
scp-682 stopped to see who had
threatened him it was almost laughable
that this thing had dared to make such a
violent threat because there was no way
that this little thing would be able to
stand up to the unkillable 682 but its
size didn't stop it from trying to pick
a fight all the same the SCP was a tiny
robot made from junk which looked more
like a sculpture made from scrap that
was found on the side of the road than a
functional automaton it said was made of
an upside down voltmeter giving it the
appearance of a smiling face and its
arms were made of wrenches it was
capable of walking around though it
seemed to have difficulty moving as it
was very top-heavy it shook a rusty fist
at scp-682 and continued to threaten him
shouting you do not know the fury you
have unleashed robo-lord the destructor
will end you as cp682 swiped at the
robot annoyed by its continued attempts
to antagonize him the robot toppled over
and struggled to stand again but when it
did it ran for 682's feet it started to
grab at 682's toes hitting them with its
wrench hands as you might expect this
had almost no effect on 682 you do
realize you are weak pathetic said 682
raising his claw to get a better look at
the annoying little robot it responded
lies and slander the mayor of Mayhem is
the most powerful being in existence
before promptly losing its grip on 682's
claw and falling to the floor now 682
was really getting tired of this thing
he prepared to swipe at it again this
time using his full strength which would
certainly smash the robot to Pieces but
luckily for the robot its pestering had
distracted 682 just long enough for the
foundation's security to sneak up on him
before 682 had a chance to smash the
robot the foundation fired on him with a
volley of rockets reducing him to a
shape and lump the security team
collected up 682's remains ready to put
them back into a backup acid tank but
the task was made slightly more
difficult by the fact that the robot was
running around underfoot trying in vain
to now attack them instead what was this
strange little robot that thought it
could attack the unkillable lizard 682
meet
scp-1370 appropriately nicknamed the
pesterbot by Foundation Personnel
pesterbot is a small robot made of junk
that displays sentience and the ability
to move despite having no power source
everything about
scp-1370 defies Common Sense the
voltmeter that serves as its head
contains no sensors but it seems unable
to see if the voltmeter is covered its
arms and legs are made of wrenches and
its wooden torso contains a speaker
which it communicates through a tinny
monotone voice pesterbot lives in SCP
Gallery 27 in a glass display case which
is 125 centimeters tall 50 centimeters
wide and 75 centimeters long level 2
personnel and higher are allowed to
remove the robot from containment at
their discretion but penalties will be
incurred for anyone who doesn't return
it to its case due to its impractical
top-heavy Design pesterbot Falls over
frequently when it walks around this led
the foundation to believe that he was
created as an art project and was later
somehow imbued with anomalous properties
rather than being made with the intent
of being sentient pesteredbot has
demonstrated at a high capacity for
learning having been taught how to speak
in English French and Latin however the
major factor hampering attempts to
further test its intelligence has
nothing to do with its robotic
processing power no it's because of its
poor attitude pesterbot's encounter with
scp-682 and the Cockiness it expressed
in the moment wasn't an aberration this
SCP really believes it's a killing
machine and as a result it will pick a
fight with anyone and anything that
moves this even includes its own
reflection and as a result the glass of
its container must be made as
non-reflective as possible to prevent
the robot from damaging the case or
itself and attempts to fight its mirror
self though it's most commonly used
nickname in the foundation is pesterbot
scp-1370 also goes by a variety of
self-given epithets including doombot
2000 robolord the destructor and Darth
claw kill Flex it can be made to add new
names to this list through encouragement
by staff and one time they even managed
to add the name pesterbot as well as the
even more ridiculous patheticon the
gargle most to its lexicon of names as
you may have surmised pesterbot is
classified safe and is treated by most
SCP Foundation employees as a humorous
Oddity rather than a legitimate threat
many tests have been done on pesterbot
and they've all conclusively determined
that the robot is incapable of
inflicting any damage to its opponents
in fact pesterbot is more a danger to
itself than to anything around it both
because it's incredibly clumsy and
awkward and because it frequently picks
fights with other scps who are far more
powerful than it one such scenario that
could have gone far worse for pesterbot
than it did was its encounter with
scp-846 also known as Robo dude one of
the many Dr wondertainment products
currently kept in Foundation containment
robodude is an ordinary looking toy
robot that upon requests can produce up
to 350 Robo accessories that function as
real weapons Robo dude can deploy
everything from a rocket launcher to a
flamethrower to a gun that shoots out an
unknown species of insect that can chew
through wood how however Robo dude seems
to not be sentient and is unable to use
these weapons unless asked to that
ultimately worked out in the favor of
pesterbot during another
scp-682 escape the two robots were
brought into contact as they both had
been broken out of their respective
containment spaces during the brouhaha
robodude searching for a robo pal to
play with Came Upon pesterbot who
immediately started spouting its usual
over-dramatic threats I am the crush
Master doomed to all I survey pesterbot
said gaze upon my might and weep
identify yourself that I might know
whose destruction I shall saw Robo dude
not programmed to know how to respond to
such a statement simply responded by
asking pestermod if it wanted to play
pesterbot continued to Trash Talk Robo
dude until Robo dude decided the best
way to play with its new pal was to
engage it in its Robo dance mode
pesterbot accepted the challenge saying
activate all that you wish but your fate
is sealed the killotron cannot be
defeated I shall render you until dust
with my mad dancing skills the two
robots proceeded to engage in a dance
battle which the awkwardly shaped Pastor
bot failed miserably at while Robo dude
was a competent dancer pesterbot could
only gyrate pathetically before it fell
over and rolled around the ground
hopelessly out of time to the music
coming from robodude speakers the song
ended and robodude declared Robo dance
is complete Robo Powell pesterbot was
unable to accept its failure and replied
ha pathetic one you have been schooled
in the art of the dance by none other
than the meccano Basher scourge of a
thousand worlds kneel before me before I
end your worthless existence Robo dude
unimpressed with pesterbot's poor
sportsmanship deployed its hydrogen
Cannon which it was programmed to do
whenever it detected a sore loser
fortunately for pesterbot hydrogen
Cannon was just the name for robo dudes
water pistol while pesterbot will
attempt to fight anything that moves the
truth is this robot will attack
virtually anything it perceives as being
even slightly alive this is perhaps best
illustrated by one of the tests of
pesterbot's abilities that involve
putting a small speaker at the base of a
potted houseplant and speaking through
it from another room the plant was
placed across from pesterbot in the
testing chamber and the interaction was
monitored by researchers from outside
researcher Davey spoke through the
speaker in the plant pot he asked
pesterbot if he could hear him and it
answered who does all cells will burn
you will feel the sharp sting of my
wrath identify yourself so that I may
sing damnation upon you as you die the
robot began approaching the plant Davies
speaking as the plant identified himself
I'm a split leaf philodendron a
semi-woody shrub with large glossy
leaves at this point he had to try very
hard not to laugh at the absurdity of
this test and the robot's reaction he
continued these leaves can grow up to
three feet long Pastor Botta used its
wrench to try and wrestle with the
leaves but was bested by the mighty
plant and unable to cause any damage
enraged by its failure it said your
mockery spous your Dome I have arrived
you will be crushed betwixt my digits
pesterbot then fell over and was unable
to write itself it struggled and spent
six minutes trying to stand before its
flailing knocked over the plant which
did nothing to help and in fact pinned
the robot to the ground it was at this
point that the researchers who had taken
time to compose themselves after several
laughing fits enter the chamber and
remove pesterbot in order to place it
back in its containment case despite how
non-threatening pesterbot is there is
actually one situation in the
foundation's history where it actually
posed a somewhat serious threat when
mobile task forces were sent in to
rescue survivors of the events at site
13 also known as
scp-1730 they were attacked by alternate
universe versions of a variety of
creatures kept in Foundation containment
one of these creatures was pesterbot who
in that Universe somehow gained control
of a larger mechanical body constructed
of discarded pieces of Machinery it
threw other pieces of metal scrap at the
task force as they tried to leave the
site shouting in a much deeper and more
intimidating voice I am reborn to
breathe Devastation upon this fetid
Earth pitiful humans you will feel the
dark sting of my never-ending torment
members of the task force could see the
original pesterbot body on top of the
larger metal construct waving its arms
madly the task force opened fire to
little effect pesterbot tossed another
piece of scrap at them just narrowly
missing one Task Force member threw a
frag grenade at the robot which it
caught blowing up its hand another one
was able to jump into the air and reach
the tiny robot atop the larger body
knocking it against the wall and
shattering it even in the reality where
pestrobot was able to build itself a
larger body it still ultimately wasn't
able to put up that much of a fight poor
pesterbot doomed to be a failure in this
and apparently every other reality
that's the story of scp-1370 also known
as pesterbot one of the most hilariously
harmless anomalous entities that the
foundation currently has in containment
perhaps one day he'll achieve his goal
of Conquering the universe he just has
to figure out how to conquer his toy box
first now check out scp-001 the Scarlet
king and scp-999 the Tickle Monster for
more fascinating beings from the SCP
Foundation
[Music]